ich rufe auf den Tagesordnungspunkt 7
vereinbarte Debatte zu den sechs
nachhaltigkeitsprinzipien der deutschen
Nachhaltigkeitsstrategie
für die Aussprache wurde eine Dauer von
180 Minuten vereinbart
ich eröffne die Aussprache und zuerst
hat das Wort für die Bundesregierung die
Bundesministerin für wirtschaftliche
Zusammenarbeit und Entwicklung Svenja
Schulze und ich freue mich Ihr heute
auch zu ihrem Geburtstag gratulieren zu
können herzlichen Glückwunsch
[Musik]
herzlichen Dank Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen sehr geehrte
Damen und Herren es geht hier heute um
Nachhaltigkeit und zwar um
Nachhaltigkeit als Richtschnur der
deutschen Politik und die deutsche
Nachhaltigkeitsstrategie die liegt dafür
quasi den roten Faden fest das ist die
konkrete Umsetzung der Agenda 2030 der
Vereinten Nationen und das Gute an
dieser Strategie ist sie macht Erfolge
sichtbar aber sie zeigt auch sehr klar
wo die Herausforderungen am größten sind
und wo wir besser werden müssen das ist
so eine Strategie in dieser Art und
Weise gibt das ist wirklich weltweit
beispielgegend die soziale und
ökologische Transformation ist ein ganz
zentraler Baustein für nachhaltige
Entwicklung aber auch das steht vor
großen Herausforderungen wir haben es
hier im Parlament diskutiert globale
Krisen der Klimawandel die
corona-pandemie die Auswirkungen des
angriffskriegs in Russland auf die
Ukraine das alles verstärkt sich
gegenseitig und bringt auch das was wir
an Fortschritt schon erreicht haben
inzwischen wieder ins Stocken und es
zeigt sich deutlicher denn je wir müssen
gemeinschaftlich Handeln Solidarität ist
der Schlüssel zur Umsetzung der Agenda
2030 und es geht darum ein besseres
Leben für alle Menschen auf der Welt zu
organisieren ohne dass wir dabei unseren
Planeten ruinieren
die Bürgerinnen und Bürger können nicht
mehr alleine mit nationalen Gesetzen vor
den Folgen des globalen Klimawandels
geschützt werden unsere
Ernährungssicherheit unsere
Energieversorgung unsere
Arbeitsbedingungen unsere Zukunft hängt
davon ab dass wir gemeinsam als
internationale Gemeinschaft hier
Lösungen schaffen und das heißt im
Umkehrschluss nachhaltige Entwicklung
ist nur dann in Deutschland möglich wenn
wir uns global dafür einsetzen und das
umfasst drei Ebenen in Deutschland durch
Deutschland in multilateralen Bündnissen
und wird Deutschland in bilateraler
Zusammenarbeit mit unserem
Partnerländern und genau das treibt dort
die deutsche Entwicklungszusammenarbeit
voran durch internationale Allianzen und
Kooperationen mit Zivilgesellschaft
Wirtschaft und Wissenschaft trägt das
Entwicklungsministerium weltweit zu
strukturellen Veränderungen bei und wir
arbeiten gemeinsam mit den
Partnerländern an Lösungen für die
dringendsten heraus Anforderungen und
dazu gehört ohne Zweifel die
Transformation hin zur Klimaneutralität
wir brauchen eine globale Energiewende
bei der Gerechte Übergänge und gute
Arbeit sichergestellt wird dafür ist
international der Begriff just
transition gefunden worden es ist keine
Frage bei eine klimagerechte Wirtschaft
bei steigendem Energiebedarf zu schaffen
das ist ein immenser Kraftakt das gilt
hier für uns in Deutschland das gilt
aber noch mehr für unsere Partnerländer
und mir ist wichtig dass wir diesen
Übergang zu Klimaneutralität sozial
gerecht gestalten Klimaschutz gelingt
nur mit sozialer Sicherheit
als konkret bedeutet das dass wir als
was ich als entwicklungsministerin unser
Engagement für saubere und für sichere
energieausbauern werden um eine sichere
Zukunft für alle Menschen zu ermöglichen
wir unterstützen unsere Partnerländer
dabei gute klimagerechte Beschäftigung
zu schaffen und leistungsfähige soziale
Sicherungssysteme zu stärken betreiben
eine sozialökologische Transformation
der Wirtschaft und einen nachhaltige
Umgestaltung der Finanzwirtschaft voran
und wir helfen armen Länder dabei sich
besser an den Klimawandel anzupassen die
Artenvielfalt die natürlichen
Lebensgrundlagen von uns allen zu
schützen und wir setzen uns dafür ein
Städte klimagerechter zum mit
lebenswerten Wohnraum für alle Menschen
zu machen ein Beispiel wie das
funktioniert sind die just energy
transition partnerships wie wir sie im
Rahmen der G7 mit Südafrika auf dem Weg
gebracht haben oder die bilateralen
Partnerschaften ich war ja bereits in
Ländern wie zum Beispiel Ruanda oder
auch indien ist einer der Partner die
Cote Diva mit dem wir solche
Partnerschaften anstoßen im Rahmen
dieser Partnerschaft unterstützen wir
dann die Länder beim Kohleausstieg und
dem Aufbau von alternativer
Energiegewinnung und dabei gilt es dann
sozial gerechte Strukturen aufzubauen
die dann auch wirklich alle Beteiligten
einbeziehen so können dann wirklich
lokale Wertschöpfung
Ausbildungsmöglichkeiten qualifizierte
Arbeitsplätze in einer zukunftsindustrie
geschaffen werden und das macht die
Länder schrittweise unabhängiger von
fossilen Energiequellen von einseitigen
Lieferbeziehungen und es können darüber
hinaus noch exporterlöser erzielt werden
das ist ein Gewinn für soziale
Gerechtigkeit und für Klimaschutz
Instrumente wie diese
energiepartnerschaften tragen direkt zu
den Prinzipien der deutschen
Nachhaltigkeitsstrategie bei es gilt
jetzt die nötigen Investitionen zu
tätigen es geht jetzt die weich
vorstellen für widerstandsfähige und
nachhaltiges Gesellschaften weltweit
sozial gerechte Gesellschaften in denen
eine gleichberechtigte Teilhabe am
politischen am wirtschaftlichen Leben
für alle Menschen möglich ist und zwar
nicht nur weil das gerecht ist sondern
auch weil die Ergebnisse dann deutlich
besser sind kurz gesagt Deutschland
nimmt seine internationale Verantwortung
war die Bundesregierung setzt sich für
eine soziale wirtschaftliche und
ökologische Entwicklung ein in
Deutschland und weltweit nicht trotz der
vielen Herausforderungen sondern weil
diese gezeigt haben das globale Krisen
nur global gelöst werden können
Klimawandel Pandemie Konflikte und
Kriege dürfen nicht gegeneinander
ausgespielt werden sondern ihre Ursachen
müssen gleichzeitig angegangen werden
wer denn je ist es notwendig die Ziele
der Agenda 2030 als internationale
Gemeinschaft zu erreichen das von Zielen
das beschließen von Maßnahmen ist dabei
nicht genug wir müssen unsere
Anstrengung verstärken um grundlegende
strukturelle Veränderungen zu erwirken
und zwar jetzt die deutsche
Nachhaltigkeitsstrategie da muss dazu da
dazu wirksam und verbindlich beitragen
und das tut sie herzlichen Dank
nächster Redner für die
cdu/csu-fraktion Felix schreiner
ja sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen sehr geehrte
Frau Bundesministerin Schulze auch von
unserer Fraktion gratulieren wir ihn
sehr herzlich zu ihrem Geburtstag wenn
wir heute zur Nachhaltigkeitsdebatte im
Deutschen Bundestag zusammenkommen da
lassen uns die furchtbaren Bilder von
dem blutigen Krieg in der Ukraine
natürlich nicht kalt wir sehen jeden Tag
und es wird uns jeden Tag aufs Neue
bewusst dass sich unsere Tagesordnung
geändert hat und wir im Deutschen
Bundestag über Maßnahmen entscheiden
müssen die wir uns alle vor einem Jahr
noch nicht hätten vorstellen können
Inflation Ukraine Krieg steigender Zins
das sind die Realitäten mit denen wir
uns zu beschäftigen haben und deshalb
sind die Debatten die wir mit denen wir
die Menschen in unserem Land die
heimischen Betriebe entlasten richtig
und trotz oder gerade wegen diesem
Themen diesen Herausforderungen ist es
aber heute auch wichtig dass wir
langfristige nicht aus dem Blick
verlieren und sie ganz bewusst in den
Mittelpunkt in der Debatte hier im
Deutschen Bundestag stellen
der Dreiklang aus Ökologie aus Ökonomie
und Soziales er muss auch in
Krisenzeiten nachhaltig miteinander im
Einklang gebracht werden weil soweit
gehört wie erleben einen Klimawandel die
Zerstörung von Lebensräumen und einen
fast unersätlichen
Ressourcenhunger aber gleichzeitig
stellen wir auch fest dass fast alle
Regierungen in der Welt eine Abkehr von
solider und generationengerechter
Haushalts- und Finanzpolitik zeigen
lassen Sie uns also in dieser Debatte zu
Beginn und selbst fragen warum wir zu
sehr an das heute denken und für das
heute leben warum unser Land so sehr von
der Substanz zehrt und warum so wenig an
das morgen gedacht wird wir müssen
unsere Verhaltensweisen selbst in Frage
stellen das muss am Anfang aller
Bemühungen stehen wenn wir es ernst
meinen mit der Nachhaltigkeit in diesem
Land
und wir müssen lernen wie wir gerade in
Krisenzeiten Politik wieder stärker vom
Ende her denken das beste Beispiel dafür
ist die Einhaltung der Schuldenbremse
2014 auf den Weg gebracht hat sie die
erste schwarze Null seit 45 Jahren
geebnet es ist
es ist nicht akzeptabel wenn wir auf
Kosten künftiger Generation Leben und
ihnen einen Schuldenberg hinterlassen
den diese Generationen nie mehr abtragen
können auch das gehört zur Wahrheit am
heutigen Tag
und so weit gehört auch dass wir uns
auch wie in den vergangenen Jahren eine
nachhaltigkeitswoche gewünscht hätten
dass wir eine nachhaltigkeitswoche im
Deutschen Bundestag durchführen wie es
auf Antrag der Unionsfraktion 2020 der
Fall war die neue Mehrheit in diesem
Haus hat die Auffassung vertreten dass
eine dreistündige Debatte reicht drei
Stunden für dieses Thema kann das ihr
Ernst sein
gut also jeder blamiert sich selbst auf
dem besten wie es kann sie haben gehört
der AFD eine Stunde gereicht weil sie
dieses Thema nicht ernst nehmen können
wir Sie bei diesem Thema auch schon gar
nicht ernst nehmen das gehört auch zur
Wahrheit dazu
ich finde es auch bedauerlich dass wir
kein gemeinsamen Antrag vorgelegt haben
so wie das früher immer der Fall war wir
haben einen Antrag ausgearbeitet als
Unionsfraktion wir bringen Ihnen heute
wir legen ihn heute vor sie können in ja
gerne mit unterstützen aber sie haben es
gar nicht zugelassen dass wir über
Anträge auch debattieren und um die
nachhaltige Entwicklung krisenfester zu
machen müssen wir auch über kurzfristige
Maßnahmen in vielen Bereichen sprechen
und sie anstoßen wir fordern die
Bundesregierung deshalb auf
schnellstmöglich wieder zu einer soliden
Finanzpolitik zurückzukehren und die
Schuldenbremse einzuhalten und sagen Sie
eine klare Absage an alle in ihrer
Koalition die in Wahrheit ja nur darauf
warten die Schuldenbremse endlich außer
Kraft zu setzen das ist nicht unser Weg
das ist mit der Union nicht zu machen
wir müssen unsere Infrastruktur Stärken
dabei geht es nicht nur um den Bereich
Verkehr es geht auch um Energie um
Wasser es geht um Abwasser es geht um
Breitband es geht um die Luftreinhaltung
und es geht um die Abfallwirtschaft ich
sage es in aller Deutlichkeit es hat
auch mit Nachhaltigkeit nichts zu tun
wenn die ampelregierung das erfolgreiche
Programm
investitionspakt Sportstätten nicht
weiterführt hört sich als kleines
Projekt an ist aber in Wahrheit der
gerannt dafür für viele Städte und
Kommunen dass eine gut ausgebaute
öffentliche eine nachhaltige
Infrastruktur in den Städten ermöglicht
wird auch das gehört zur Wahrheit sie
kürzen solche Programme weil sie ihn
nicht in den Kram passen
ein weiterer Punkt ist für uns die
Sicherstellung der Ernährung wir müssen
die regionalen Produkte stärken die
Produktion stärken aber wir müssen auch
die Vielfalt von Nutzpflanzen erhalten
und die Züchtung von klimaresilienten
Sorten fördern wir alle erleben dass wir
viel besser werden müssen wenn wir die
Rahmenbedingungen anschauen wie die
Verschwendung von Lebensmittel besser
abgebaut werden kann auch da setzen wir
auf die Nutzung von Möglichkeiten von
digitalen Technologien es kann nicht
sein dass in diesem Land das so reich
ist immer noch so viele Lebensmittel Tag
für Tag verschwendet und weggeschmissen
werden
und
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen wenn
nicht den Deutschen Bundestag wo ist
denn dann eigentlich der richtige Ort
über Debatten von einem über ein gutes
Morgen und darüber zu führen wie wir uns
gemeinsam überlegen wie wir diese langen
Linien in die Tagespolitik auch umsetzen
können wir Abgeordnete haben es doch
selbst in der Hand wir können doch
entscheiden ob wir das Thema
Nachhaltigkeit auf die Agenda setzen
oder wir entscheiden darüber ob es eben
nur ein Randthema ist und wir der
Regierung zuschauen ob sie die 17
sdg-ziele einführt oder umsetzt oder
nicht aber es kann doch nicht unser
Anspruch als Parlamentarier im Deutschen
Bundestag sein dass wir dieses Thema
nicht in den Mittelpunkt der Debatte
setzen Nachhaltigkeit darf keine Floskel
sein nachhaltigkeit ist eine Frage der
politischen Überzeugung es ist aber auch
eine Frage der politischen Haltung meine
Damen und Herren und auch deshalb
diskutieren wir heute diese Debatte mit
ihnen aus ganzer Überzeugung herzlichen
Dank
Felix Schreiner aus der Unionsfraktion
Obmann im parlamentarischen Beirat für
nachhaltige Entwicklung kritisierte die
Dauer der Debatte und zwar als zu kurz
und der Verweis zu Recht darauf dass in
der vergangenen Legislaturperiode an
mehreren Tagen und auch zu den
jeweiligen Ressorts über Nachhaltigkeit
debattiert wurde hier im Deutschen
Bundestag ist Rednerin Bettina Hoffmann
stellt Parlamentarische Staatssekretärin
beim der bei der Ministerin für Umwelt
Naturschutz und nukleare Sicherheit
wir alle wissen aber was wir eigentlich
brauchen sind 52 Wochen der
Nachhaltigkeit im Jahr wir stecken tief
in einer globalen nachhaltigkeitskrise
Artensterben Klimakrise und
Umweltvergiftungen Vermüllung das sind
Symptome Folge sind auch Flucht vieler
Menschen und am Ende Kriege um Rohstoffe
und um Land es liegt in unser aller
Verantwortung wir müssen und können die
großen Herausforderungen unserer Zeit
bewältigen dafür müssen wir unsere
Anstrengung aber deutlich verstärken und
das ist der Ziel der das Ziel der
Bundesregierung
doch die Wirklichkeit die Wirklichkeit
holt uns ein die roten Linien unserer
planetaren Grenzen sind bereits
überschritten unsere natürlichen
Lebensgrundlagen sind mehr denn je in
Gefahr das Pariser Abkommen 2015 war
sicher ein historisches Ereignis erst
recht unter dem heutigen Blickwinkel
aber der weltweite
treibhausausstoß ist seitdem nicht
gesunken Hitze Dürre und Hochwasser und
Extremwetter gibt es immer häufiger das
Arten aussterben ist nicht gestoppt ganz
im Gegenteil die weltweite Verschmutzung
von Umwelt und Ozean mit Plastik und
Schadstoffen nimmt immer größere Ausmaße
an die kovid 19 Pandemie hat uns immer
noch im Griff weitere Pandemien stehen
vor der Tür und jetzt noch der
Angriffskrieg Russlands auf die Ukraine
er ist auch ein Angriff auf die mit der
Weltgemeinschaft vereinbarten
Nachhaltigkeitsziele von der Verletzung
Menschenrechte über den Einsatz von
Lebensmitteln und Energielieferungen als
erpresserische Waffe bis hin zum
Abfackeln von Erdgas zu Lasten von Klima
und Umwelt
die großen Krisen unserer Zeit fordern
uns wirklich heraus aber es muss
spätestens jetzt allen klar sein wir
müssen schneller komplexer und
international abgestimmter agieren nicht
ein Problem nach dem anderen lösen
sondern ihr umfassend im Sinne aller 17
sdgs
leider deswegen uns heute noch die
Fehler der Vergangenheit
Kohlekraftwerke aus der Reserve zu holen
lng-lieferungen zu organisieren und
sogar die letzten Atomkraftwerke über
den Winter in Bereitschaft zu halten
gegen alle Regeln der Nachhaltigkeit das
ist bitter aber wir lassen uns nicht
beirren mit Energieeffizienz Energie
einsparen und einen beherzten Ausbau der
Erneuerbaren gehen wir voran und holen
unser Land aus der Abhängigkeit von
fossilen Energien wir sorgen dafür
das niemand in Energiearmut fällt oder
Strom und gassperren ausgesetzt ist wir
schützen Unternehmen und Bürgerinnen und
Bürgern vor explodierenden Preisen das
stärkt den Zusammenhalt liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen diese
Bundesregierung ist angetreten als
zukunftsbündnis für Freiheit
Gerechtigkeit und Nachhaltigkeit wir
nehmen die internationale Verantwortung
wahr und bringen die
Nachhaltigkeitspolitik auch in
Deutschland voran trotz oder gerade
wegen der großen Herausforderung wir
konzentrieren uns auf sechs wichtige
transformationsfelder ich will das an
zwei Beispielen deutlich machen erstens
am transformationsfeld
Kreislaufwirtschaft ungefähr die Hälfte
aller globalen Treibhausgasemissionen
und 90 Prozent das atemaussterbens und
auch die Wasserknappheit sind auf die
Gewinnung und Verarbeitung von
Rohstoffen zurückzuführen es deshalb
darum mit unseren Ressourcen möglichst
schonend umzugehen sie sparsam
einzusetzen und solange sie möglich im
Kreislauf zu halten die Bundesregierung
hat sich daher das Ziel gesetzt den
primären Rohstoffverbrauch zu senken und
geschlossene Stoffkreisläufe zu schaffen
in einer nationalen
kreislaufwirtschaftsstrategie werden wir
gemeinsam mit allen Akteuren die
bestehenden rohstoffpolitischen
Strategien bündeln auch die Flut von
einwegplastik die noch viel zu oft in
der Umwelt landet soll so bewältigt
werden
das führt mich zum transformationsfeld
schadstofffreie Umwelt saubere Luft
gesunde Gewässer und intakte Böden sind
überlebenswichtig für Mensch und Natur
deshalb unterstützt die Bundesregierung
das von der EU-Kommission ausgerufene
Null verschmutzungszielen und ergreift
auf nationaler Ebene Maßnahmen für eine
giftfreie Umwelt deshalb
bereiten wir einen Aktionsplan vor gegen
hormonell schädliche Stoffe deshalb
suchen wir nach Lösungen um den Einsatz
schädlicher und langlebiger Chemikalien
wie Pipas zu reduzieren deshalb stimmen
wir eine nationale wasserstrategie ab
die unter anderem dazu beitragen soll
dass unsere seenflüsse und Meere wieder
gesünder werden deshalb haben wir
erstmals einen meeresschutzbeauftragten
der Bundesregierung benannt er wird auch
die internationalen Bemühungen um ein
Abkommen gegen die Vermüllung der Meere
vorantreiben
unser Handeln muss auch und gerade in
Krisenzeiten dazu beitragen dass wir
unsere natürlichen Lebensgrundlagen
besser schützen das verlangt das Urteil
des Bundesverfassungsgerichts aber auch
die schlichte Verantwortung gegenüber
unseren Kindern und Enkeln
wir müssen und werden die
Nachhaltigkeitspolitik der
Bundesregierung insgesamt modernisieren
wir wollen die Verbindlichkeit von
Nachhaltigkeitszielen erhöhen sei es im
Klima und wieso diversitätsschutz bei
den Bürgerrechten und in der nationalen
in der deutschen
Nachhaltigkeitsstrategie selber wir
werden außerdem Fortschritte beim
sdt-gipfel 2030 voranbringen nur mit
einer ambitionierten Umsetzung der
Agenda 2030 werden die Lebens- und
entwicklungsschancen dieser und
künftiger Generationen besser als bisher
gewahrt und die Krisen unserer Zeit
bewältigt es kann gelingen das globale
Engagement besonders junger Menschen für
eine lebenswerte Zukunft stimmt mich
sehr zuversichtlich
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
nachhaltigkeit heißt die aktuellen
Krisen anzugehen und dabei die
langfristigen nicht aus den Augen zu
verlieren die Woche der Nachhaltigkeit
ruft das in Erinnerung daran will ich
mit ihnen arbeiten nicht nur diese
sondern alle kommen Wochen vielen Dank
Bettina Hoffmann Parlamentarische
Staatssekretärin bei der
Bundesumweltministerin die hier anwesend
ist und ich hatte jetzt zuletzt auch den
Eindruck dass Frau Hoffmann diese Rede
stellvertretend gehalten hat wir klären
das mal zwischenzeitlich Rainer Kraft
ist am Pult für und aus der afd-fraktion
ob man im parlamentarischen Beirat für
nachhaltige Entwicklung Kollegen wir
debattieren heute über die sechs
Prinzipien der deutschen
Nachhaltigkeitsstrategie die deutsche
Nachhaltigkeitsstrategie behauptet in
mit der Neufassung der Prinzipien eine
bessere Übereinstimmung mit der Agenda
2030 der Vereinten Nationen gebracht zu
haben aber ist das wirklich der Fall die
Prinzipien fordern unter anderem den
halte natürlichen Lebensgrundlagen
weiterhin den Schutz der Umwelt und die
Nutzung erneuerbarer Naturgüter nur im
Rahmen ihrer Regenerationsfähigkeit
soweit so gut allerdings stellt sich
dann natürlich die Frage wie sie bei zum
Beispiel wäre Energiepolitik begründen
bei der sie die ab haben tausende Hektar
an Fläche in industrielle
brachlandschaften zu verwandeln sind
Wälder denn keine natürliche
Lebensgrundlage doch das sind sie sind
Wiesen und Weiden etwa keine Umwelt doch
ja das sind sie auch und wie sieht
eigentlich die natürliche
Regenerationsfähigkeit eines
verdichteten ex-waldstückes aus auf dem
nun eine 160 Meter hohen tausende Tonnen
schwere stahlbetonsäule prank genannt
Windrad ja da ist dann keinerlei
regenerationsfähigkeiten mehr gegeben
ergo widerspricht ihr totaler und
radikaler Ausbau der fälschlicher
erneuerbar bezeichneten Energien den
Nachhaltigkeitsprinzip Nummer 3
des weiteren fordertprinzip 3 mit nicht
nachwachsenden Naturgütern so sparsam
wie möglich umzugehen warum aber setzt
dann die Bundesregierung auf diejenigen
energieerzeugungsmethoden die bei
größtmöglichen Materialeinsatz die
geringsten energetischen Ausbeuten
erzielen wie Windindustrie und
PV-Anlagen
beides widersprechen natürlich dem
nachhaltigkeitsziel Nummer 7 der Agenda
2030 der Vereinten Nationen für eine
bezahlbare zuverlässige nachhaltige und
moderne Energieversorgung
neu ist das nicht ich habe in das von
dieser Stelle aus vielfach schon gesagt
die aber von ihnen der Regierung und ja
leider auch von den beiden anderen
Oppositionsparteien favorisierte
Energiepolitik mittels Wetter Tages- und
jahreszeitenabhängige Energien führt
eben zu einer teuren und zur
verlässlichen archaischen und damit eben
nicht nachhaltigen Energieversorgung
das führt dann natürlich auch dazu dass
ihre Energiepolitik auch dem Prinzip mit
4 und 5 widerspricht das mit dieser
teuren Energie kein nachhaltiges
Wirtschaften mehr möglich ist bzw diese
Verteuerung den sozialen Zusammenhalt
gefährdet statt ihn zu verbessern
ja und die ersten
Stern
lose verfrieren bereits und sie nennen
diese Politik ernsthaft nachhaltig
wirklich
ja kommen wir noch einmal zur Einhaltung
der planetaren Grenzen
ja die werden im Winter wieder
funktionieren helenker keine Sorge es
ist eine der erfolgreichsten Lügen das
Rohstoffe durch die Nutzung verbraucht
werden das ist nicht der Fall diese Güte
werden gebraucht und sind auch nach
Beendigung des Gebrauchs als Materie
grundsätzlich vorhanden und die uns
bekannte Chemie und Physik ist technisch
ziemlich problemlos in der Lage alles
was nicht mehr benötigt wird wie der
nutzbare Stoffe zu wandeln und die
deutsche Nachhaltigkeitsstrategie
fordert in ihrem Prinzip 3 das explizit
nur dafür benötigt man sehr sehr große
Mengen an sehr preiswerte Energie und
hier schließt sich der Kreis durch die
falsche Energiepolitik die auf
Einsparungen setzt auf
energieerzeugungsmethoden die nur
sporadisch und dann auch nur sehr
begrenzt Energie liefern und dafür ein
Vielfaches an Flächen und
Materialaufwand benötigen sind die für
die Nachhaltigkeit nötigen Mengen einer
Energie weder erzeugbar noch bezahlbar
und damit verhindern Sie das Schließen
der stoffkreisläufer damit finden Sie
das Stoffe und Materialien wieder auf
der Rohstoffseite eingesetzt werden
können weil sie die Wiedergewinnung der
Stoffe Materialien verteuern aber damit
fördern Sie unsere Abhängigkeit von
autokratischen Regimen wie China
Saudi-Arabien Katar Aserbaidschan oder
auch Russland und anstatt in der
Energiepolitik Verzicht und Not als das
Leitmotiv zu wählen wäre es angebracht
den Aufbruch in ein Energiezeitalter zu
beginnen Mengen und Mengen ein sehr
preiswerter Energie um all die guten
Vorsätze der Gender 2030 in die Realität
umzusetzen
eine Begründung der Wüsten und eine
wirtschaftliche Entwicklung in den
schwächstenregionen dieser Welt das wäre
möglich und ja nur wenn es Deutschland
wirtschaftlich gut geht können wir
überhaupt auch nur andere Nationen noch
beistehen was sie so gern tun aber es
geht Deutschland nicht mehr gut
sie befinden sich also mit der deutschen
Nachhaltigkeitsstrategie im Konflikt mit
sich selbst und mit der Agenda 2030 und
das alles nur um der Durchsetzung ihrer
ideologischen klassenkampfziele zu
genügen die Versorgungssicherheit grüner
ideologieberufe und grüner
Vorfeldorganisationen steht bei über der
Versorgungssicherheit der Nation
der Gedanke der Nachhaltigkeit ist bis
zur Unkenntlichkeit pervertiert die
Alternative für Deutschland versteht den
Begriff der Nachhaltigkeit in seinem
ureigenen konservativen bewahrungs
genannten ressourcenschonend effizient
und dem wohl eine selbstbestimmten
eigenverantwortlichen Individuums
verpflichtet wir wehren und sowohl gegen
ihre planwirtschaftlichen Transformation
als auch ihre staatliche Umerziehung
[Applaus]
nächster Redner für die FDP-Fraktion
Christoph Meyer Christoph Meyer ist
einer der stellvertretenden Vorsitzenden
der FDP-Fraktion
frau Präsidentin meine sehr geehrten
Damen und Herren in einer Zeit in der
die Politik auf Bundes auf Landesebene
auf europäischer Ebene seit Monaten über
milliardenschwere entlastungspakete
ringt in einer Woche in der wir sehen
dass in Großbritannien die Grenzen der
eigenen schuldenaufnahmefähigkeit
getestet werden an einem Tag an dem der
Haushaltsausschuss über den Haushalt
2023 diskutiert und auch das gehört dazu
der ein oder andere
Bundestagsabgeordnete immer noch darüber
schwadroniert dass der Staat ja bei der
Bundesbank Kredite aufnehmen können und
man
kreditrückzahlungskonditionen politisch
festlegen können sind wir als FDP der
Auffassung dass wir in ein
Nachhaltigkeitsdebatte zunächst erstmal
aber fiskalische Resilienz und
finanzpolitische Stabilität diskutieren
müssen
wir werden in der Debatte jetzt
sicherlich noch einiges über die
Grundprinzipien von Nachhaltigkeit hören
und es ist glaube ich klar dass
Disziplin und Priorisierung dazugehört
priorisiere und nutze nur so viel wie du
tatsächlich brauchst handle mit
langfristiger Perspektive und
hinterlasse deinen Kindern keine
schweren Hypotheken deshalb haben wir
als FDP in diesen Koalitionsvertrag die
Schuldenbremse reinverhandelt und dazu
stehen wir auch nach wie vor
da kann da kann die Union klatschen und
es wäre schön wenn die CDU ihren
Kollegen aus Bayern denn auch klar macht
dass auch sie dafür sind der ein oder
andere aus Bayern scheint das ja nicht
ganz richtig verstanden zu haben
wir erleben auch das in der Debatte
glaube ich noch ein bisschen zu kurz
gekommen eine ökonomische Zeitenwende
die Zeit ist nullzinses ist vorbei und
wenn wir über Schuldentragfähigkeit
sprechen uns vergegenwärtigen dass wir
im Jahr 2023 30 Milliarden Euro
zinskostenkosten tragen müssen dann ist
das ein Volumen im Vergleich zu 2021 wo
der gesamte Etat des Umweltministeriums
ist Außenministeriums des Ministeriums
für Familie reingehen würde und das
macht die Dimension deutlich weswegen
ist wichtig ist dass wir als Koalition
wir als FDP vorneweg das
Finanzministerium die Schuldenbremse
auch im Jahr 2023 verteidigen werden und
zwar nicht damit irgendwelche
allgemeinen politischen Vorhaben
finanziert werden können sondern dass
wir das nötige machen in der Krise auf
der einen Seite auf der anderen Seite
aber solide Haushalten und die
Zukunftsfähigkeit dieses Landes sichern
und die Schuldenbremse ist daher auch
ein nachhaltigkeitsförderer die
Schuldenbremse wird in den nächsten
Jahren die Politik zwingen
sich zu priorisieren in allen
Einzelplänen in allen Bereichen werden
wir den Gürtel ein Stück weit enger
schnallen müssen weil wir nur so die
Regeln einhalten werden und das wird
nach zehn Jahren ungezügelten Wachstum
was
etat-ansätze angeht was
stellenansätze angeht auch sehr sinnvoll
sein wir werden deswegen
Planungsprozesse beschleunigen zum
Beispiel lng-terminals wir finden es
eigentlich eine sehr gute Entwicklung
dass jetzt lng-terminals schnell gebaut
werden was in den letzten Jahren
versäumt wurden wir werden Bürokratie
abbauen und digitalisieren und wir
werden
wirkungsorientierte Haushaltspolitik
einführen damit das Geld effizienter
eingesetzt werden kann auch das gehört
zur Wahrheit dazu dass der Staat alleine
all die ganzen Ziele die hier auch
bisher genannt wird nicht schaffen
werden können mit eigenen Leistungen
sondern wir brauchen private
Investitionen private Problemlöser und
auch dafür steht die FDP dass das in den
nächsten Jahren zu kurz kommt wir sind
wir sind bei aller Kritik was die
ökologische Nachhaltigkeit was den
Klimaschutz angeht in Deutschland schon
weltweit führend was die finanzielle
Nachhaltigkeit angeht haben wir noch ein
wenig Aufholbedarf und wir werden dafür
sorgen dass die Ampel auch das nicht aus
dem Blick verliert ich danke Ihnen
Christoph Meyer FDP-Fraktion dort einer
der stellvertretenden Vorsitzenden in
der vereinbarten Debatte des Deutschen
Bundestags zur deutschen
Nachhaltigkeitsstrategie ein weites Feld
ein zukunftsorientiertes Feld und da
spricht jetzt Bernd Riexinger aus der
Linksfraktion wo er Sprecher für
nachhaltige Mobilität ist
geehrte Damen und Herren die Zukunft der
Menschheit hängt nach einer aktuellen
Studie des Club of Rom von fünf
kehrtwänden ab Beendigung der Armut
Beseitigung der eklatanten Ungleichheit
Ermächtigung der Frauen
Aufbau eines für Menschen und Ökosysteme
gesunden nahrungsmittelsystems Übergang
zum Einsatz sauberer Energie das ist
Nachhaltigkeit im umfassenden Sinne
damit umschreibt der Klappe from
prägnant dass wir uns in einer
geschichtlichen Phase
multipler Krisen des Kapitalismus
befinden die sich gegenseitig
verschränken und verschärfen und ohne
eine radikale Änderung der Wirtschafts-
und Lebensweise werden diese Krisen
nicht gelöst werden
wir wissen dass wir nur noch 15 Jahre
Zeit haben um die Weichen radikal
umzustellen für den Körper from ist
Gleichheit und Gerechtigkeit der
Königsweg für eine lebenswerte Zukunft
also ungefähr das pure Gegenteil von dem
was die ampelregierung Macht und die
größte Oppositionspartei gemacht hat von
einer Beendigung der weltweiten armut
kann keine Rede sein aber die bisherige
Politik schafft es nicht einmal in einem
der reichsten Länder der Welt Armut und
Kinderarmut erfolgreich zu bekämpfen
die Ungleichheit ist während der
Pandemie noch größer geworden sie
schaffen es nicht einmal eine
lächerliche übergewinnsteuer auf den Weg
zu bringen oder in irgendeiner Form
reiche und Vermögende an den Kosten der
Krisen zu beteiligen von der Forderung
des Körpers Rom dass die reichsten zehn
Prozent die Investitionen für
Klimaschutz aufbringen müssen sind sie
weiter entfernt als die Erde vom Mond
statt die Menschen zu entlasten die es
dringend benötigen machen Sie ein
inflationsausgleichsgesetz bei dem die
am meisten entlastet werden die ohnehin
die höchsten Einkommen haben wir sind
eines der wirtschaftlich stärksten
Länder
bei denen die Frauen immer noch
durchschnittlich 20% weniger verdienen
als die Männer wann wird endlich der
Grundsatz eingelöst gleicher
lohnvergleichwertige Arbeit
und beim Übergang zum Einsatz sauberer
Energien hat Deutschland längst seine
Vorreiterrolle verloren statt der
Forderung von frei.day for future
nachzugehen nämlich einen Klimaschutz
vor von 100 Milliarden einzurichten
rüsten Sie lieber die Bundeswehr um 100
Milliarden auf sie schaffen es nicht
einmal bei der Energieknappheit ein
Tempolimit zu verabschieden von einer
nachhaltigen mobilitätswende die diesen
Namen verdient ganz zu schweigen für
einen sozialökologischen Systemwechsel
müssen Gerechtigkeit und
Klimagerechtigkeit
zusammengedacht werden dazu sind wir
bereit danke schön
Bernd rexinger aus der Linksfraktion das
ist ja die Fraktion die die meisten
aktuellen und ehemaligen
Parteivorsitzenden in ihren Reihen hat
auch Bernd Riexinger Weiher mal
Vorsitzender der Linken einige Jahre
sogar ihm folgt jetzt am Pult Sarah
rücklewski Staatsministerin für Bund
länderbeziehung beim Bundeskanzler und
ist sie ist auch zuständig für die
Koordination von Nachhaltigkeitszielen
in den einzelnen Ressorts der
Bundesregierung hat nachhaltige
Entwicklung als men to the moon Projekt
beschrieben
der mundflug unserer Generation so
Professor Sachs und ich zitiere mit
Erlaubnis der Präsidentin ist die
nachhaltige Entwicklung auf der Erde um
Erfolg zu haben bedarf es einer nicht
weniger mutigen Kraftanstrengung als
beim Mondflug
aus dem Weltall wirkt unsere Erde wie
ein großes Raumschiff so hat es der
deutsche Isar Astronaut Matthias Maurer
in diesem Jahr bei seiner Rede beim
Weltwirtschaftsgipfel in Davos
beschrieben er war dabei von der
internationalen Raumstation zugeschaltet
das ändert die Perspektive und er hat
hinzugefügt die Crew die Menschheit
sollte zusammenarbeiten um die
Herausforderungen unserer Zeit zu
bewältigen
und dieses gemeinsame anpacken ist heute
wichtiger denn je gerade auch vor dem
Hintergrund des brutalen angriffskriegs
Russlands gegen die Ukraine natürlich
hat dieser Krieg es wäre
illusorisch zu denken dass es anders
wäre Auswirkungen auf die Frage wie wir
unsere sdg-ziele erreichen können aber
er macht auch noch mal sehr deutlich
dass eigentlich kein Weg an ihnen
vorbeiführt wir merken gerade dass die
Abhängigkeit von fossiler Energie in
zweierlei Hinsicht und nachhaltig auch
beeinflusst wir sind zum einen von der
Endlichkeit abhängig zum anderen machen
wir uns auch bei der Kompensation immer
wieder von Staaten im Zweifelsfall
abhängig die unsere Werte nicht teilen
und die SDG geben wir uns auch in der
Langfristperspektive eine Möglichkeit
aus diesem Dilemma rauszubekommen denn
mit den 17 Sustainable Development Goals
der Agenda 2030 haben sich alle Staaten
zur gemeinsamen Verantwortung bekannt
für gute Lebensperspektiven heutiger und
künftiger Generationen
zusammenzuarbeiten internationale
Zusammenarbeit ist der Schlüssel zur
Lösung unserer globalen Probleme
und schon seit 2002 hat Deutschland eine
Nachhaltigkeitsstrategie sie ist der
Rahmen für die deutsche Umsetzung der
Agenda 2030 und wurde zuletzt 2021
überarbeitet die Strategie enthält 75
konkrete Ziele sowie die Ex
nachhaltigkeitsprinzipien über die wir
heute sprechen die Ziele aber auch die
Prinzipien zeigen nachhaltigkeit ist für
alle Politikbereiche von großer
Bedeutung das erste
Nachhaltigkeitsprinzip fordert
nachhaltige Entwicklung als Leitprinzip
in allen Bereichen und bei allen
Entscheidungen anzuwenden und
Bundesministerin Svenja Schulze und die
Parlamentarische Staatssekretärin
Hoffmann haben das ja auch sehr
eindrücklich für ihre Politikbereiche
auch dargestellt
aber wir dürfen uns nichts vormachen wir
müssen richtig richtig auf die Tube
drücken bei dem Thema wir haben nur noch
sehr sehr wenig Zeit um die sdgs zu
erreichen und wir müssen hier eine
Schippe drauflegen und da hat sich die
Bundesregierung und Koalitionsvertrag
ein ambitioniertes Ziel gesetzt wir
wollen die 17 sdgs als Richtschnur
unserer Politik umsetzen und hierfür
werden wir die Nachhaltigkeitsstrategie
konsequent weiterentwickeln
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen das
Bundeskabinett hat mich am 24 August mit
der Zuständigkeit für nachhaltige
Entwicklung betraut zusammen mit allen
Bundesministerien arbeiten wir daran im
staatssekretärsausschuss für nachhaltige
Entwicklung und wir wollen das
tatsächlich Nachhaltigkeit zur
Richtschnur der Politik der
Bundesregierung wird dafür ist aus
meiner Sicht zweierlei wichtig alle
Ministerien müssen im Ausschuss aktiv
mitwirken und Sie müssen das als ein
Instrument nutzen um ihre Politik an
Nachhaltigkeit auszurichten
das ist bis jetzt der Fall wer hat deine
erste sehr sehr gute Sitzung wo auch
alle wirklich sehr committed waren
Helmut Kleber liegt gerade er war auch
mit dabei weil auch das gehört dazu wir
möchten den Austausch haben nicht nur in
diesem Ausschuss Regierung und
Parlament Regierung nicht nur den
Austausch innerhalb der Regierung
sondern wir wollen aktiv auf Sie als
Parlament zugehen deswegen gerne auch
die Einladung an die
CDU-Bundestagsfraktion ich komme auch
gerne zu Ihnen und wir diskutieren über
das Thema weil wir eben aus der Blase
raus müssen und wir wollen diesen
Ausschuss auch als Strategie Forum
nehmen denn Nachhaltigkeit das hat die
Debatte hier gezeigt dass ein gutes
Thema ist ein wichtiges Thema ich finde
auch es ist ein schönes Thema aber es
darf kein wohlfühlthema werden auch das
hat die Debatte gezeigt wir erleben doch
am Ende wenn es konkret geht wenn es um
die Frage geht wie wir Politik auch
genau ausrichten dann haben wir
natürlich Differenzen aber diese
Differenzen die müssen wir ausreichen
die müssen wir aus diskutieren nur so
schaffen wir wirklich Fortschritte im
Bereich der Nachhalt Möglichkeit
ich möchte insbesondere die sechs
transformationsbereiche hervorheben die
wir zum Schwerpunkt der Arbeit im
Ausschuss in den kommenden Monaten
machen werden natürlich gehören dazu die
Bereiche Klima und Energie das hat ja
auch hier die Debatte geprägt es gilt
aber auch für das Thema kreiswirtschaft
eine schadstofffreie Umwelt nachhaltige
agrar- und ernährungssysteme bauen und
Verkehr und natürlich immer wieder wenn
es um das Wohl der Menschen geht die
soziale Gerechtigkeit und nach meiner
Überzeugung ist die Transformation
Deutschlands zu einer nachhaltigen
Gesellschaft die beste Antwort auf die
weltweite klima-energie und
rohstoffkrise die wir derzeit erleben
und damit ist die wichtiger denn je
aber
Transformation wir reden immer so viel
darüber die muss auch irgendwo konkret
stattfinden und deswegen müssen wir an
einem Strang ziehen deshalb freue ich
mich sehr dass ich am Montag in
Vertretung für den erkrankten
Bundeskanzler Olaf Scholz gemeinsam mit
dem Ministerpräsidenten von
Nordrhein-Westfalen hinweg wüst das vom
Nachhaltigkeitsrat koordinierte
Gemeinschaftswerk nachhaltigkeitsstaaten
durfte das Gemeinschaftswerk soll
bundesweit eine Plattform sein für alle
Aktivitäten im Bereich der
Nachhaltigkeit von den lokalen
Nachhaltigkeitsinitiativen über
Sportvereine die Mittelstand Kommunen
bis hin zu Dax-Konzernen die sich für
einen nachhaltige Gesellschaft einsetzen
auch hier geht es wieder darum wir
müssen konkret werden wir müssen das in
der Politik sicherstellen dass wir die
Rahmenbedingungen dafür schaffen dass
Nachhaltigkeit auch gelebt werden kann
dass sie umgesetzt werden kann aber wir
müssen auch eine Plattform dafür
schaffen damit es am Ende konkret
stattfinden kann
Nachhaltigkeit ich habe das vorhin
gesagt es ist ein gutes Thema und das
zeigt auch dass dieses Thema von vielen
Akteuren mitgetragen wird das sehen wir
gerade jetzt in der europäischen
nachhaltigkeitswoche in diesem Jahr gab
es wieder mehr als 6.000 Aktivitäten in
25 europäischen Ländern alleine in
Deutschland
3.800 und ich möchte ganz deutlich sagen
ganz herzlichen Dank an alle die
mitgemacht haben
und mein herzliches Dankeschön gilt an
dieser Stelle auch an den
parlamentarischen Beirat für nachhaltige
Entwicklung für seine wichtige Arbeit in
den vergangenen Jahren aber nach allem
was ich gehört habe möchten Sie sich ja
auch noch mal neu aufstellen auch in der
Frage wie wir dann auch bei
Gesetzgebungsvorhaben genau darauf
schauen ob das Prinzip Nachhaltigkeit
umgesetzt wird ich freue mich da sehr
auf den Dialog den Diskurs und
vielleicht auch mal auf ein paar
Reibereien wenn wir mal gesagt bekommen
hier ist das noch nicht umgesetzt worden
aber genau darum muss es gehen wir
müssen hier genauer hinschauen wir
müssen auch nachhalten und im
Zweifelsfall dann auch nachbessern
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen ich komme
zum Schluss ich möchte noch einmal
bekräftigen die Bundesregierung wird
sich weiter für eine nachhaltige
Entwicklung einsetzen ganz im Sinne des
Koalitionsvertrags als Bündnis für
Freiheit Gerechtigkeit und
Nachhaltigkeit und deswegen achten wir
über Parteigrenzen hinweg darauf dass
wir mit unserem wirken nicht nur den
Bedürfnissen der heutigen gen Richtung
gerecht werden sondern wir immer auch
die Bedürfnisse der künftigen
Generationen im Blick haben und einen
Satz möchte ich aber dann doch einem
noch mal sagen weil wer darüber
gesprochen haben dass es vielleicht auch
mal Differenzen gibt ich glaube es gibt
Schulden die man vererben kann es gibt
aber auch Hypotheken die man vererben
kann weil man an anderer Stelle nichts
getan hat und zu wenig investiert hat
vielen Dank
Sarah rücklewski Staatsministerin beim
Bundeskanzler so ist ja der offizielle
Titel koordiniert das Thema
Nachhaltigkeit zwischen den
verschiedenen Ressorts in einer
stadtsekretärsrunde und hat vorhin
gesagt dass dort alle sehr committed
waren also sich dem Thema verpflichtet
fühlen so kann man es mal übersetzen
Ralf Brinkhaus aus der Unionsfraktion
ist ebenfalls Mitglied im
parlamentarischen Beirat der hier schon
so häufig angesprochen wurde das was ich
in den letzten Jahren erlebt habe mal
als folgendes und zwar als seriellen
Alarmismus was bedeutet serieller
Alarmismus wir haben immer ein Thema da
ist Vollalarm das ist voll von den
Debatten hier in den Talkshows an den
medialen Lagerfeuern in den Zeitungen
und alle anderen Themen fallen heben wo
hinten runter es ist so dass mich
gestern in einer Schülergruppe eine
Schülerin gefragt hat redet ihr
eigentlich noch über kovic wir machen
uns da irgendwie Sorgen was da im Winter
passiert oder habt ihr nur noch ein
Thema meine Damen und Herren das ist
verständlich dass wir momentan dieses
große Thema Russland und die Folgen und
Energiekrise haben das ist auch sehr
sehr menschlich aber wenn sie mal die
letzten Jahrzehnte so zurückblicken gab
es nicht immer irgendwie ein großes
Thema was viel viel wichtiger war seit
angefangen irgendwann mal mit der
Finanz- und Bankenkrise die war dann
ganz wichtig dann die Eurokrise Teil 1
dann ist Fukushima hochgegangen dann war
die Euro-Krise Teil 2 dann haben wir nur
über Migration geredet dann hatten wir
noch den Trump dann hatten wir noch den
brexit und dann hatten wir zum Schluss
kobit immer ein großes Thema alle
anderen Sachen sind dabei irgendwie
hinten rübergefallen jetzt will ich
nicht sagen sagt gar nichts gemacht
worden ist aber nicht mit der genügenden
Aufmerksamkeit ich habe das gesehen als
ich mich 2018 gefragt habe als wir
irgendwie sehenden Auges in eine
Situation hineingerannt sind dass wir
unsere Klimaziele nicht erreichen wie
konnte das eigentlich passieren denn
eigentlich gab es auch damals schon
Strategien eigentlich ist auch damals
schon was gemacht worden eigentlich hat
man auch damals schon Sachen umgesetzt
und trotzdem war immer irgendetwas
Wichtigeres zu tun und immer war
irgendein Thema entscheidender als das
Thema Klima Umwelt und Nachhaltigkeit
und wir brauchen das gar nicht auf
Umwelt
wir rennen momentan gegen eine Wand bei
den Sozialversicherungssystem und ganz
ehrlich wir wissen doch alle dass die
Abhängigkeit die wir von Russland haben
Kindergeburtstag ist gegenüber der
Abhängigkeit von China das heißt meine
Damen und Herren nachhaltige
langfristige Themen die Fallen irgendwie
immer hinten rüber warum ist das so wir
haben wir haben jetzt eine Debatte zum
Thema Nachhaltigkeit ein großes Dach für
viele Themen meine Vorrednerinnen und
Redner haben das auch beleuchtet und das
wird auch heute noch beleuchtet werden
ist eben nicht nur Klimapolitik nicht
nur Umweltpolitik sondern es geht um
Armut es geht um Hunger es geht um
Gesundheit es geht um Gleichstellung und
viele viele andere Sachen aber jetzt
fragen wir uns doch mal wo fließt das
denn in unserem politischen Alltag ein
da gibt es erstmal eine gute Nachricht
die gute Nachricht ist die Vereinten
Nationen haben sich auf 17 Ziele zur
Nachhaltigkeit geeinigt
und wenn man weiß wie schwierig es ist
auf dieser Ebene ein Konsens zu finden
ist das erstmal wunderbar dass das
überhaupt möglich ist es gibt eine
zweite gute Nachricht diese Ziele sind
sogar untersetzt worden mit Indikatoren
mit Kennzahlen das heißt Politik ist
nicht nur im Ungefähren man müsste mal
man könnte mal und es muss besser werden
nein es gibt konkrete Indikatoren wie
man sowas messen kann beispielsweise
Herr Ritzinger beim Thema Armut die
Menschen die weniger als 1,25 Dollar zur
Verfügung haben es gibt Zahlen zu Frauen
in Führungspositionen es gibt Zahlen zu
Übergewicht zu Rauchern und natürlich
auch die Klimaziele die Zahlen gibt es
und die dritte gute Nachricht meine
Damen und Herren ist diese Zahlen werden
sogar gemessen jedes Jahr hier in
Deutschland beispielsweise von
Statistischen Bundesamt Euro-Staaten ist
die Zahlen die Vereinten Nationen geben
jedes Jahr einen Bericht heraus wie die
ganze Sache sich weiterentwickelt
aber hat das ein Einfluss auf unsere
politische Tätigkeit hier ist es so dass
wir morgens aufstehen und sagen hey
welches nachhaltigkeitsziel nehmen wir
uns heute mal vor wo arbeiten wir heute
dran was machen wir dagegen das wird in
einem Ampelsystem gemacht dass die
Ampeln bei der ein oder anderen Kennzahl
auf Rot oder auf gelb ist nein unser
politisches Tagesgeschehen wird auch
davon geprägt dass wir versuchen den Tag
zu gewinnen dass wir versuchen abends
unfallfrei ins Bett zu kommen und dass
man vielleicht nebenher noch mal das ein
oder andere erledigen kann und ich sage
das ist jetzt kein Thema meine Damen und
Herren zwischen Opposition und Regierung
das geht uns allen an das ist übrigens
auch kein Thema zwischen Politik und
Medien das geht uns alle an und da
müssen wir uns alle in die Augen schauen
was da passiert ja und Frau reglewski
natürlich haben wir ein
staatssekretärsausschuss stellt sich nur
die Frage wieso ist es eigentlich nicht
ein hochkarätiger ministerausschuss wenn
es so wichtig ist wieso ist dieser
Staatssekretär als Ausschuss erst nach
neun Monaten in Gang gesetzt worden und
früher ja wir haben einen Rat für
Nachhaltige Entwicklung da wird tolle
Arbeit gemacht da war die Tagung am
Montag ja wir haben auch ein
parlamentarischen Beirat für nachhaltige
Entwicklung und die Kolleginnen und
Kollegen sitzen hier und die sind alle
ganz ganz ganz engagiert aber hat das
was da besprochen wird Auswirkung auf
das was wir hier in Gesetze reingießen
ich sage ganz ehrlich viel zu wenig und
jetzt
es könnte ich
sagen
Opposition jammern ist genug ich werfe
ein paar Steine und es ist alles
schlecht Nein
das reicht nicht weil eins ist auch
richtig wir sind hier der Deutsche
Bundestag wir sind das Parlament wir
haben es in der Hand das zu ändern wir
können dem Thema eine Bühne geben das
machen wir heute mit drei Stunden hätte
mir ein bisschen mehr Leidenschaft in
der Debatte gewünscht an der ein oder
anderen Stelle das machen wir heute in
drei Stunden aber da sitzt der Kollege
Mirsch wir haben es vereinbart wir
wollten eigentlich eine Woche raus
machen wir hätten hier die Gelegenheit
gehabt in einer Woche genauso wie wir es
bei den Haushaltsberatungen machen jedes
nachhaltigkeitsziel zu besprechen jeden
Minister zu hören die
oppositionsvorschläge zu hören wir
hätten die Gelegenheit gehabt wirklich
das in die Öffentlichkeit zu bringen was
viele leider viel zu wenig wissen diese
Gelegenheit die haben wir verpasst das
ist jetzt vergossene Milch das wird
nichts mehr ich werbe wirklich dafür
dass die Mehrheit es anders macht und
dass die Mehrheit es beim nächsten Mal
mit uns beschließt dass wir wirklich
eine nachhaltigkeitswoche machen und
Einsatz gestatten Sie mir noch frau
Präsidentin reden reicht nicht weil
geredet wird genug dass es mal besser
werden müsste ich sogar noch für eine
weitere Sache und das vielleicht so ein
bisschen als gedankenfutter für die
weitere Debatte ich werde dafür dass wir
genauso wie wir einen Haushaltsplan
aufstellen wo wir alle
haushaltskennzahlen in einem Buch
hineinschreiben und darüber sprechen
dass wir alle nachhaltigkeitskennzahlen
in einem nachhaltigkeitsplan beraten
dass wir uns genauso zwei Wochen wie für
die Haushaltsberatung Zeit nehmen und
dass wir dann die Regierung daran messen
ob diese Zahlen ob diese Ziele jährlich
erfüllt worden sind oder nicht das wäre
nachhaltig und damit würden wir
Nachhaltigkeit in den Deutschen
Bundestag bringen herzlichen Dank
Ralf Brinkhaus aus dem parlamentarischen
Beirat für nachhaltige Entwicklung mit
einem sehr grundsätzlichen mit einem
sehr nachdenklichen Beitrag in dieser
Debatte über den politischen Alltag und
über die und zu der Frage dass Politik
häufig nur in Tagesaktualität gedacht
und wird auch Berichterstattung nur auf
tagesaktuelle Entwicklungen ausgerichtet
wird aber langfristig nur langfristig
lösbare Aufgaben dann häufig hinten
runterfallen und auch die Debatten dazu
am Pult bzw auf dem Weg dorthin jetzt
Tessa gansera ob Frau im
parlamentarischen Beirat für nachhaltige
Entwicklung und heute morgen schon bei
uns im Interview
freut es mich sehr dass wir heute hier
an einem prominenten Zeit Platz zum
Thema Nachhaltigkeit
debattieren und meine Vorbereitung
meiner Rede habe ich mir Gedanken
gemacht wie die Debatte wohl verlaufen
wird und ich habe mich ganz bewusst
entschieden nicht in ein
parteipolitisches Kleinklein zu
verfallen weil mir weil dieses Thema in
der nachhaltigen Entwicklung einfach
viel zu wichtig ist und wie die
bundesministerins Svenja Schulze und
auch die Staatssekretärin Bettina
Hoffmann schon deutlich gemacht haben es
geht hier um nichts Geringeres als dafür
zu sorgen dass alle Menschen hier in
Deutschland aber auf dem kompletten
kommt auf der kompletten Planeten ein
gutes Leben in Würde führen können und
dass wir das auch unseren Enkelkindern
und urenkelkindern ermöglichen müssen
und dafür
ist es notwendig dass wir alle unsere
Lebens- und Wirtschaftsweise so
gestalten dass dabei die ökologischen
Belastungsgrenzen unseres Planeten nicht
überschritten werden und ich möchte an
dieser Stelle positiv herausheben dass
wir hier eine eigentlich einen breiten
parteipolitischen Konsens haben seit
2002 gibt es in Deutschland eine
Nachhaltigkeitsstrategie an der die
jeweilige Bundesregierung und zwar
unabhängig von ihrem parteipolitischen
Farbzusammensetzung festgehalten hat und
diese Nachhaltigkeitsstrategie jeweils
auch fortgeschritten hat
nichtsdestotrotz müssen wir ehrlich
feststellen dass mir vom Erreichen der
Nachhaltigkeitsziele national wie Global
noch meilenweit davon entfernt sind und
zur aktuelle Krisen wie die
corona-pandemie oder jetzt dieser
fürchterliche an der Krieg stellen uns
natürlich vor
unerwarteten
Herausforderungen auf die wir auch
kurzfristig Antworten finden müssen aber
wir dürfen dabei natürlich das
langfristige Ziel dann nachhaltigen
Entwicklung nicht aus den Augen
verlieren und wir müssen deswegen unsere
Kraftanstrengung auch noch intensivieren
damit man diese Ziele nicht nicht
verpassen dass wir die Ziele der UN auch
erreichen
der Staatssekretär in den Ausschuss für
nachhaltige Entwicklung hat jetzt
erstmals sogenannte
transformationsteams eingesetzt an den
eine
ressortübergreifend an denen der
Nachhaltigkeitsstrategie festgelegten
transformationsbereichen eines hoher
übergreifend vernetzt zusammengearbeitet
werden soll und ich erachte das für ein
wahnsinnig wichtigen Schritt weil
nämlich hier bei einer Umsetzung der
Nachhaltigkeitsstrategie alle
Ministerien mitarbeiten müssen
darüber hinaus ist es meiner Überzeugung
dringend notwendig dass wir die
Nachhaltigkeit
Überprüfung in der gesetzesfolgen
Abschätzung so wie im Koalitionsvertrag
vereinbart auch noch mehr Gewicht
verleihen dazu muss von einer formalen
Überprüfung diese Nachhaltigkeit zu
Überprüfung zu einer qualitativen
Prüfung weiterentwickelt werden und eben
auch der Klima-Check mit eingebunden
werden weil beides ergänzt und bedingt
sich miteinander ich würde sogar wir
gehen kurz raus aus der laufenden
Debatte über die deutsche
Nachhaltigkeitsstrategie gegen aber
gleich wieder zurück nach Berlin in die
Debatte die noch den ganzen Vormittag
laufen wird um dem anzuschauen in die
bundespressekonferenzen und hier im
Reichstagsgebäude wird wieder über die
langfristigen Themen diskutiert über die
langfristigen Probleme Lösungen nicht
über kurzfristige Vorhersagen es geht um
die nationale
Nachhaltigkeitsstrategie um die
nachhaltigkeitsprinzipien wir haben hier
verschiedene Aspekte schon gehört in den
vergangenen
knapp anderthalb Stunden die diese
Debatte läuft weitere anderthalb Stunden
wird sie auch mindestens noch dauern
fürs gab beim sehr interessanten
Redebeitrag von Ralf Brinkhaus aus der
Unionsfraktion der genau dieses Thema
die Kurzsichtigkeit in der auch die
Politik gelegentlich handelt dass sie
die langfristigen Ziele gelegentlich aus
den Augen verliert weil ein serieller
Alarmismus vorherrscher so hat er es
vorhin formuliert in seinem Redebeitrag
und hat dabei am Rande auch die Medien
erwähnte die dann die langfristigen
Themen die langfristigen Problemlösungen
gelegentlich ein wenig außer Acht lassen
jetzt wie gesagt aber hier noch die
Debatte zur Nachhaltigkeitsstrategie im
Moment sind Finanzpolitiker am Pool zum
Beispiel Anja Schulz aus der
FDP-Fraktion
möglich und bei dem der Taschenrechner
nicht zu dem Ergebnis kommt dass sich
Arbeit im Alter nicht mehr lohnt
unsere rentenpolitischen Forderungen
sind nicht nur ein wichtiger Schritt für
eine nachhaltige Finanzierung sondern
vor allem das Signal an junge Menschen
an nachfolgende Generationen dass sie
dem Staat vertrauen können das
Generationengerechtigkeit so wie es
bisher war nicht nur eine Phrase bleibt
sondern wirklich gelebt wird alle Bürger
auch wenn sie noch nicht wählen können
haben ein Recht darauf von der Politik
geachtet zu werden das ist nachhaltig
[Applaus]
nächste Rednerin für die Fraktion DIE
LINKE Anke domscheid Berg und Anke
domscheitberg ist Sprecherin für
digitalpolitik in der Linksfraktion
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen
wenn wir von Nachhaltigkeit reden müssen
wir auch vom Zusammenhang zwischen
Klimakrise und Digitalisierung reden wo
Digitalisierung Teil des Problems aber
auch der Lösung ist Energie und
Verkehrswende gehen gar nicht ohne
Digitalisierung wenn wir weg wollen vom
Individualverkehr und hin zum
bedarfsgerechten ÖPNV heißt das auch
dass ich mir ein Minibus auf Abruf über
eine App im ländlichen Raum in
Niedersachsen oder Brandenburg bestellen
kann aber Digitalisierung ist eben auch
Teil des Problems der
Ressourcenverbrauch ist enorm vor allem
auch bei der Herstellung elektronischer
Geräte bei unseren Handys zum Beispiel
sind drei Viertel der CO2-Emissionen
allein auf die Herstellung
zurückzuführen laut Greenpeace Daten und
wenn wir alle unsere Smartphones statt
durchschnittlich drei Jahren Europa vier
Jahre verwenden würden könnten wir zwei
Millionen Tonnen CO2 in Europa einsparen
der Neukauf wird aber leider oft
erzwungen weil man die Akkus nicht
vernünftig wechseln kann und weil es
keine Sicherheitsupdates mehr gibt
deshalb hoffe ich dass die Ampel das
angekündigte Recht auf Reparatur und die
mindest-updatepflicht langjährige
Forderungen der Linksfraktion auch zügig
umsetzt
aber die Bundes
Regierung zweifach Verantwortung nicht
nur als Regulierer sondern auch als
Großverbraucher für über eine Milliarde
Euro kauft der Bund jedes Jahr it ein
und der Energieverbrauch der Bundes-IT
könnte mit seinen 335 Gigawattstunden
134.000 zwei Personen Haushalte
versorgen deshalb habe ich eine kleine
Anfrage zur Nachhaltigkeit der Bundes-IT
gestellt und ganz frisch zurückbekommen
die Antwort kam leider mit sehr vielen
Lehrstellen zwei Drittel der 184
Rechenzentren des Bundes konnten nicht
mal sagen ob sie erneuerbare Energie
benutzen ob die IT nach der
einkaufsrichtlinie auch tatsächlich
nachhaltig eingekauft wurde keine Ahnung
es gibt ja kein Monitoring die
Datenqualität war außerdem wirklich
mangelhaft es gab viele falsche Angaben
und auch widersprüchliche beim BMI haben
Rechenzentren Kälte kälteschädliche
Kältemittel als umweltfreundlich
bezeichnet das zeigt das Reporting ist
ziemlich kaputt und die
kompetenzmangelhaft
immerhin meine Kleine Anfrage hat bei
der Ampel auch etwas angestoßen nämlich
eine Vereinheitlichung und Erweiterung
des Berichtswesens zur Nachhaltigkeit in
der IT wurde noch während der
Beantwortung der Kleinen Anfrage
beschlossen das zeigt linke Opposition
wirkt
da wo es Daten gab war die
Nachhaltigkeit erschreckend schlecht
nicht einmal jedes zehnte Rechenzentrum
nutzt die Abwärme und nicht einmal jedes
dritte nutzt erneuerbare Energien neun
einziges der 184 Rechenzentren erfüllte
Kriterien des blauen Engels
verrechenzentren aber zwei Drittel
nutzen klimaschädliche Kältemittel es
soll jetzt eine energieeffizienzregister
für Rechenzentren in Deutschland kommen
aber die dateneintragung ist wohl nur
freiwillig und das fürchte ich wird
nichts bringen
die Ampel will sich nach ihrer
digitalstrategie daran messen lassen
dass Methoden energieeffizienter
Softwareentwicklung etabliert sind das
finde ich super denn ineffizient
ineffiziente Software verursacht viermal
so viel Energieverbrauch wie effiziente
aber der Bund der selbst sehr viel
Software entwickelt oder Entwicklung
beauftragt hat nicht eine einzige
Software die mit dem Blauen Engel für
Energieeffizienz ausgezeichnet ist auch
sonst weiß sie nichts darüber denn es
gibt keine Verbindlichkeit und keine
einheitlichen Vorgaben sie hat keine
Ahnung vom Status im eigenen Haus aber
auch die it-konsolidierung bleibt ein
Problemfall sie sollte zur
Nachhaltigkeit beitragen durch eine
Reduktion der bundesrechenzentren ihre
Anzahl aber das Milliardengrab wird
jetzt auch zur Hürde für nachhaltiger it
ja die Anzahl der Rechenzentren steigt
einfach immer weiter auch in den
nächsten Jahren wie immer gilt schöne
Ziele nutzen nichts wenn es am Ende an
Umsetzungskompetenz fehlt ich bin
trotzdem gespannt auf die angekündigten
Maßnahmepläne zur klimaneutralen
Bundesverwaltung und zur green
it-initiative als linke Opposition sind
wir gerne bereit fachliche Expertise
dazu einzubringen denn die Klimakrise
erfordert gemeinsames Handeln vielen
Dank
danke domscheitberg die Sprecherin für
digitalpolitik in der Linksfraktion und
wir schauen auf den nächsten Redner
Helmut Kleebank ist der Vorsitzende in
einem Gremium das nicht ganz so präsent
ist in der Öffentlichkeit aber heute
schon der ist nämlich Vorsitzender im
parlamentarischen Beirat für nachhaltige
Entwicklung und er war
Bezirksbürgermeister in Spandau fand die
Jahrestagung des Rates für nachhaltige
Entwicklung statt in allen Debatten an
diesem Tag gab es rund um die
Nachhaltigkeit eine zentrale
generationenübergreifende gemeinsame
Botschaft es gab eine Forderung die
immer wieder deutlich erhoben wurde sie
lautete wir brauchen bei der Umsetzung
der vorhandenen Konzepte für
nachhaltiges Wirtschaften und
nachhaltiges Leben deutlich mehr Tempo
Tempo war der meist gewählte Begriff an
diesem Tag
und das war nicht die tempob-grenzung
auf der Autobahn gemeint
und das stimmt gemessen an dem
jahrelangen voll auf den wir hatten ist
zu wenig wirksames passiert denn bereits
vor sieben Jahren im September 2015
verabschiedeten die Staats- und
Regierungschef der 193 Mitgliedsstaaten
der Vereinten Nationen die Agenda 2030
mit ihren 17 Nachhaltigkeitszielen vor
drei Jahren im September 19 kamen
ebenfalls die Staats- und
Regierungschefs zu dem Ergebnis dass
diese 17 systemebälle Development Goals
verfehlt werden wenn sich die zu diesem
Zeitpunkt aktuellen Trends fortsetzen
daraufhin haben die Vereinten Nationen
bei ihrem sdg-gipfel das Jahrzehnt der
2020er Jahre zur aktionsdekade erklärt
auch die Bundesregierung erkennt dieses
Ziel an und arbeitet mit der deutschen
Nachhaltigkeitsstrategie für das
Erreichen dieser Ziele wir haben dazu
einiges gehört hier im Parlament wurde
in den vergangenen Monaten in allen
Bereichen eine große Zahl von Gesetzen
verabschiedet die beim Bereichen der
sdgs auf jeden Fall helfen werden ich
persönlich bin stolz darauf eine
Parlament anzugehören das Nachhaltigkeit
nicht nur verbal ernst nimmt sondern mit
großem Einsatz und inzwischen auch mit
deutlich mehr Tempo in die Tat umsetzt
allerdings
und jetzt kommt der Wermutstropfen
stelle ich fest dass wir uns als
Parlament immer noch einige Defizite
leisten blinde Flecken sozusagen die wir
uns meines Erachtens nicht leisten
sollten ich will das kurz begründen und
benennen die Beschäftigung mit den 70
Nachhaltigkeitszielen zeigt ganz
unschwer dass sie eng miteinander
verknüpft sind in zum Teil sehr
unterschiedlicherweise bedingen oder
beeinflussen sie sich gegenseitig die
Bundesregierung hat dieser Tatsache mit
der Formulierung von und der
Konzentration auf 6 sogenannte
transformationsbereiche Rechnung
getragen auch das ist vorgetragen worden
jeder transformationsbereich adressiert
eine Gruppe von sdgs die untereinander
in besonders engem Zusammenhang stehen
im Deutschen Bundestag wird diese
Tatsache dieser sinnvolle vernetzte
Ansatz bislang unzureichend abgebildet
ein zweiter blinder Fleck die schnelle
und wirksame Bekämpfung der globalen
Krisen wie zum Beispiel der Erderwärmung
des Artensterbens oder der
Überschwemmung des Planeten mit
Plastikmüll
gelingt nur mit einem internationalen
Kraftakt und auf dieser internationalen
Bühne auch das wurde von den
internationalen Gästen unter anderem von
wellen-generalsekretärin
Johnson surf der
friedensnobelpreisträgerinnen und
ehemaligen Präsident Liberias am Montag
sehr deutlich gemacht auf der
internationalen Bühne wird sehr genau
auf die Transformation in Deutschland
und auf Deutschlands Rolle der globalen
Transformation geachtet
in diesen beiden Aspekten der Arbeit an
den transformationsbereichen und der
Wechselwirkung zwischen nationalem und
internationalem handeln muss sich der
Deutsche Bundestag meines Erachtens
selbst ertüchtigen wie komme ich zu
dieser Einschätzung der parlamentarische
Beirat für nachhaltige Entwicklung der
für all diese Fragen das prädestinierte
Gremium darstellt hat bislang weder den
Status noch die faktischen Möglichkeiten
in diesen übergreifenden Fragen
gegenüber der Regierung in besonderer
Weise für das Parlament wirksam zu
werden wenn wir uns im September
nächsten Jahres mit dem Zwischenbericht
des pwne beschäftigen wird dieser
Bericht auch Vorschläge für die
Weiterentwicklung des Beirats enthalten
lassen Sie uns als Parlament gemeinsam
daran arbeiten und dafür sorgen dass er
auch Antworten auf die hier
aufgefrorenen aufgeworfenen Fragen
enthält und dass wir diese dann auch
gemeinsam in die Tat umsetzen vielen
Dank
Helmut Kleeberg der Vorsitzende des
parlamentarischen Beirats für
nachhaltige Entwicklung und falls Sie
über eine Abkürzung eine englische
gestolpert sein sollten es die Jeans hat
er gesagt die wörtliche bedeutet
wörtliche Sustainable Development Goals
also nichts anderes als
Nachhaltigkeitsziele nach Helmut klebe
an dem Vorsitzenden des
parlamentarischen Beirats jetzt der
stellvertretende Vorsitzende eben dieses
Gremiums Wolfgang stefinger
Arbeit und Wohlstand jedoch ohne ihre
Lebensgrundlagen zu zerstören die
anderen wollen den Wohlstand erhalten
und ausbauen und müssen dies
nachhaltiger tun als bisher wenn wir
heute über Nachhaltigkeit sprechen zu
müssen wir einen Blick auf Entwicklungs-
und Schwellenländer richten denn zur
Wahrheit gehört unser Wohlstand ist eng
mit Entwicklungsländern verknüpft es
gibt ja immer wieder Stimmen die meinen
Entwicklungsländer gingen uns nichts an
das ist ein fataler Irrtum wir haben
nämlich alle täglich mit
Entwicklungsländern zu tun haben sie
heute morgen einen Kaffee getrunken wo
kommen die Bohnen her
haben Sie vielleicht die Jeans angezogen
wo wird die Baumwolle angebaut und wo
wir diese Kleidung genäht können die
näher davon leben die Bestandteile der
Batterien für die Handys für die E-Autos
für die Laptops wo kommt das Kobalt her
das Lithium die Liste ließe sich also
beliebig fortsetzen
2014 wurden die 17 Nachhaltigkeitsziele
beschlossen mit dem Ziel diese bis 2030
auch zu erreichen doch wo stehen wir wir
haben es heute auch schon gehört
Stichwort Armutsbekämpfung Kampf gegen
Hunger die Zahlen steigen wieder auch
durch Corona beim Thema Umweltschutz und
Erhalt der Biodiversität haben wir
Nachholbedarf beim Thema bezahlbare und
saubere Energie weltweit sind tausende
Kohlekraftwerke geplant gehen sie ans
Netz ist die Erreichung des
zweigrad-ziels unmöglich meine sehr
geehrten Damen und Herren diese
Beispiele sollen verdeutlichen warum wir
das Thema Nachhaltigkeit nicht isoliert
beobachten können nicht nur auf
Deutschland bezogen nicht nur auf Europa
bezogen sondern weltweit wir müssen
begreifen dass wir eine Welt sind und
für sie alle gemeinsam Verantwortung
tragen deshalb
möchte ich auch drei Gedanken nennen wie
wir gemeinsam als eine Welt nachhaltiger
werden können erster Punkt
Entwicklungssprünge ermöglichen und
nutzen was heißt das für
Entwicklungsländer geht es nicht darum
Entwicklungen unsere Entwicklungen
nachzuholen sondern es geht darum
Entwicklungsschritte auch zu
überspringen und direkt auf neue auf
Umwelt auf klimafreundliche Technologien
auf nachhaltige Technologien zu setzen
und wer wenn nicht wir wer wenn nicht
unser gewissenschaft unsere Wirtschaft
könnte hier unterstützen liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen in Afrika
wächst die Bevölkerung am schnellsten
und wird sich bis 2050 sogar verdoppeln
bereits heute haben auf dem
afrikanischen Kontinent 600 Millionen
Menschen keinen Zugang zu Strom
in Afrika wird in den kommenden zehn
Jahren so viel gebaut werden wie in
Europa in den vergangenen hundert Jahren
gebaut wurde die Fragen sind also ob der
Strom aus fossilen oder erneuerbaren
Quellen erzeugt wird ob mit Stahl und
Beton oder mit nachwachsenden Rohstoffen
gebaut wird auch darüber oder auch daran
wird sich entscheiden ob sich der
Klimawandel Bremsen lässt oder nicht
deshalb sage ich ganz deutlich
Nachhaltigkeit
Nachhaltigkeit liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen ist Entwicklungspolitik oder
anders gesagt Entwicklungspolitik ist
weltweite
Nachhaltigkeitspolitik und das hier
gespart wird in diesem Etat ist das
falsche Signal der Bundesregierung
die
die Union meine sehr geehrten Damen und
Herren hat in den vergangenen 16 Jahren
hier eine Vielzahl auf den Weg gebracht
Stichwort energiepartnerschaften
Frau Künast vielleicht nehmen uns mal
ein paar Baldriantropfen dass etwas
ruhiger werden
hat wirklich einiges auf den Weg
gebracht Stichwort
energiepartnerschaften diese gilt es
auszubauen diese gilt es zu stärken
Afrika könnte rechnerisch ganz Europa
mit Solarenergie versorgen wieso nutzen
Sie liebe Bundesregierung die aktuelle
Krise nicht um diese Partnerschaften
auch zu stärken liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen das größte Solarkraftwerk der
Welt in Marokko ist ein gutes Beispiel
ein Beispiel für gemeinsame
Investitionen ein Beispiel für
internationale Zusammenarbeit ein
Beispiel wie Technik unter anderem aus
Deutschland einen Beitrag zur
Nachhaltigkeit leisten kann ich sage
Ihnen eines wir brauchen mehr davon
zweiter Gedanke
es braucht auch und wir sehen das ja wie
eng wir verbunden sind die Welt ist ein
globales Dorf alleine auch was die
Lieferketten betrifft es braucht auch
faire Lieferketten es braucht Fernhandel
und faire Produktion aber fair darf kein
Nachteil sein für die Unternehmen
sondern es muss ein Vorteil sein und
deswegen müssen wir dieses Thema auch in
internationalen Abkommen die man im
übrigen auch wollen muss Liebe grüne
auch entsprechend müssen diese Abkommen
auch Regeln enthalten und auch die
europäische Handelspolitik muss einen
Beitrag zu diesen Nachhaltigkeitszielen
leisten wir als Union haben in der
letzten Wahlperiode einen ersten
wichtigen Schritt mit unserem
lieferkettengesetz gemacht
Dritter Gedanke
Dritter Gedanke es braucht weltweite
Standards nachhaltigkeit bedeutet auch
globale Güter zu schützen und
Verantwortung für das Gemeinwohl zu
übernehmen die Politik kann Regeln
festsetzen dass es klar aber es kommt
auch auf uns alle an
meine sehr geehrten Damen und Herren bei
Nachhaltigkeit geht es um den Erhalt
unserer Lebensgrundlagen ökologisch
wirtschaftlich sozial und kulturell es
geht um Gerechtigkeit gegenüber Menschen
in anderen Teilen der Welt und gegenüber
kommenden Generationen es geht um
Chancengleichheit sozialen Zusammenhalt
und es geht um Frieden vielen Dank
Wolfgang stefinger aus der
Unionsfraktion aber auch als
stellvertretender Vorsitzender des
parlamentarischen Beirats für
nachhaltige Entwicklung hat noch mal
aufgezeigt wie groß und wie breit und
wie wichtig auch das Feld nachhaltigkeit
ist und das ist tatsächlich nicht nur um
Umwelt und Naturschutz geht nächster
Redner wird sein Jan Niklas gesenhus
oder ist in der Fraktion Bündnis 90 die
Grünen Sprecher für Umwelt und
Naturschutz
Kolleginnen und Kollegen man konnte sich
heute bei den unionsreden Live angucken
was es bedeutet sich einen schlanken Fuß
zu machen und ich will ihn mal eins
sagen was ich noch nie leiden konnte was
ich noch nie leiden konnte ist sich über
Jahre mal so richtig austoben ein riesen
Saustall zu hinterlassen und dann den
anderen zu sagen so jetzt macht das mal
bitte schon weg übernehmen sie endlich
mal Verantwortung für das was sie in
ihrer Regierungszeit gemacht haben
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen wir
brauchen eine ambitionierte
Nachhaltigkeitspolitik um noch lange
frei und sicher auf diesem Planeten
leben zu können es geht um unsere
Freiheit und es geht um unsere
Sicherheit um nichts weniger
und richtig ist dafür braucht es alle
drei Säulen der Nachhaltigkeit Umwelt
Wirtschaft und Soziales aber war es auch
diese drei Säulen der Nachhaltigkeit
sind auch nicht einfach unbegrenzt
miteinander austauschbar und ich will
das mal sehr deutlich sagen sie können
Ökosystemleistungen sie können die
Leistung der Natur Wasserhaushalt
Luftreinhaltung Artenvielfalt die können
sie nicht einfach technisch ersetzen das
ist unmöglich und dieses Bewusstsein
fehlt ganz oft und das ist Teil des
Problems und das genau das ist auch Teil
des Problems in ihrem Antrag Liebe
Unionsfraktion weil wenn ich mir das mal
so angucke was sie da in ihren
Forderungen ausschreiben dann lese ich
dann nichts zum Naturschutz nichts zur
Biodiversität und nicht mal was zu
Wasserkrise nach diesem dürresommer das
ist einfach schwach Liebe Union
und weil dieses Bewusstsein so fehlt
überschreiten wir unsere planetaren
Grenzen massiv Staatssekretärin Hoffmann
hat vorhin darauf hingewiesen und durch
dieses Überschreiten der planetaren
Belastungsgrenzen schränken wir unsere
Freiheit ein und unsere Sicherheit ein
und zwar nicht wie manche das
suggerieren durch neue Gesetze und neue
Regeln sondern durch eine dramatische
über Nutzung unserer natürlichen
Lebensgrundlagen das sehen wir beim
Flächenverbrauch das sehen wir bei der
rohstoffausbeutung das sehen wir auch
beim dramatischen Zustand der Meere und
Wälder und damit müssen wir Schluss
machen meine Damen und Herren mehr
Nachhaltigkeit um unsere Freiheit und
unsere Sicherheit auch für kommende
Generationen zu sichern
und ich will das mal auch ganz deutlich
sagen das gilt auch gerade jetzt in der
Krise
Angriffe auf Umwelt und Naturschutz
jetzt in der Krise sozusagen die Krise
dafür zu instrumentalisieren das ist
völlig fehl am Platz lassen Sie das
bitte weil weil wir kriegen die Krise
nicht bekämpft durch Abstriche bei
Umwelt und Naturschutz sondern was in
der Krise hilft sind ernsthafte
Vorschläge Ernsthaftigkeit wirksame
Konzepte und keine ablenkungsdebatten
lassen sie uns zu Ernsthaftigkeit
zurückkehren meine Damen und Herren dann
geben wir die richtigen Antworten auf
die Krise
und deswegen erhalten wir gerade jetzt
das was uns erhält und das was uns
erhält das ist ein global umspannendes
Netz der Arten und Ökosysteme und weil
wir in dieser massiven
biodiversitätskrise sind brauchen wir
globale antworten weil es eben auch eine
globale Krise ist und deswegen ist es
gut dass die Bundesregierung sich
einsetzt für ein ambitioniertes
Schutzabkommen für die Biodiversität für
ein Abkommen gegen die plastikvermüllung
für ein Abkommen für den Schutz auf
hoher See dass die Bundesregierung 1,5
Milliarden für die globale
biodiversitätsfinanzierung zur Verfügung
stellt und dass wir national vorangehen
mit vier Milliarden Euro für den
natürlichen Klimaschutz ich kann nur
sagen weiter so und ich freue mich wenn
daran auch alle wirklich alle Ressorts
mitmachen vielen Dank
sagt Jan Niklas gesenhues aus der
Fraktion Bündnis die 90 die Grünen ihm
wird jetzt
folgender aus der afd-fraktion wo er
auch entwicklungspolitischer Sprecher
ist
[Applaus]
frau Präsidentin meine Damen und Herren
Scholz Habeck und baerbock wollen nicht
zitiere aus der Nachhaltigkeitsstrategie
der Bundesregierung den sozialen
Zusammenhalt stärken Armut überwinden
und inklusiven Wohlstand fördern Zitat
Ende wo hat das links gelbe Bündnis
Armut überwunden
wo haben sie inklusiven Wohlstand
geschaffen machen wir doch mal ein
Realitätscheck Lindner lässt auf Sylt
die Korken knallen Frau Lambrecht kehrt
mit dem Sohnemann in Berliner luxusclubs
ein Habeck gibt uns Tipps zum Duschen
und Frau baerbock stellt fremde
Interesse über deutsche
und Thomas für die unfähigen Minister
und Wollpullover für frierende Bürger
meine Damen und Herren
inklusiven Wohlstand fördert diese reg
nur für sich selber die Bürger in
Deutschland sind ihnen doch völlig egal
anstatt Nord Stream 2 zu öffnen lässt
diese Regierung zu das kritische
Infrastruktur in die Luft gesprengt wird
anstatt Kernkraftwerke weiter laufen zu
lassen für diese Regierung einen
peinlichen Eiertanz auf um grüne
Fantasiewelten vor der Realität zu
schützen anstatt mit höchster Priorität
ein
inflationsschutzgesetz auszuarbeiten
schreibt diese Regierung lieber die
hundertste Neuauflage des
Infektionsschutzgesetzes damit wir im
Winter beim frieren auch noch Maske
tragen können
und anstatt sofort auf alle Maßnahmen
einzugehen und diese zu ergreifen damit
Bürger und Unternehmen ihren Strom und
ihre Gasrechnungen zahlen können
verschenken sie auch dieses Mal wieder
elf Milliarden Euro
Entwicklungsleistungen ins Ausland auf
inklusiven Wohlstand für die Damen und
Herren der Regierung verzichten wir
gerne wenn es dafür wieder Politik mit
exklusiven Bezug zu Realität gibt
nächster Redner für die FDP-Fraktion
Jens teutrine und er ist Mitglied im
Ausschuss für Arbeit und Soziales und
Sprecher für Bürgergeld auch das Jahr
ein Aspekt von Nachhaltigkeit allen
Reden gehört es gibt mehrere Dimensionen
der Nachhaltigkeit wir haben nicht nur
die ökologische Nachhaltigkeit sondern
selbstverständlich auch die Frage
ökonomischer und sozialer Nachhaltigkeit
die sind auch in den 17 Zielen der
Verhalten Nationen festgeschrieben und
ein Aspekt ist ja auch die Bekämpfung
von Ungleichheit der da festgeschrieben
ist und da geht es auch um die Frage wie
ist denn die nachhaltige Sozialpolitik
gestaltet in unseren Land und es wurde
bereits angesprochen und ich erlebe das
auch immer wieder in Diskussionen dass
Sozialpolitiker dann als besonders
sozial Glauben zu gelten wenn Sie viel
Geld ausgeben gucken wir aber bereits in
der Verteilung des Geldes geben wir eine
Billion Euro in soziale System immer in
Deutschland bereits aus ein Drittel des
Bruttoinlandsprodukts fließt in die
verschiedenen Systeme von Rente bis
Gesundheit in den Sozialstaat rein und
deswegen glaube ich es eine nachhaltige
Sozialpolitik nicht daran gemessen
werden sollte wer mehr Geld ausgibt
sondern die Frage ist ist das Geld was
sich ausgebe auch wirksam bekämpft ist
ungleichheitsdimensionen
schafft es Aufstiegschancen für junge
Menschen oder zementiert ist obwohl ich
so viel Geld ausgebe eigentlich
weiterhin
ungleichheitern es ist wirklich Hilfe
zur Selbsthilfe oder mache ich einiges
vielleicht nur aus einem guten Gewissen
deswegen ist eine wichtige
nachhaltigkeitsdimension und der
Fortschritt von sozialer Politik misst
sich nicht am unverteilungsrat sondern
an der Wirksamkeit von den Maßnahmen und
der Aufstiegschance und dann und dann
ist es sehr prominent auch dann wenn es
um Ungleichheiten geht neue Steuern zu
fordern in den Glauben wenige
Superreiche besteuern zu können wird
dann sehr gerne die Vermögensteuer
wieder ins Spiel gebracht in der
jetzigen Situation eine Gefahr für die
Substanz des Mittelstandes in
Deutschland jetzt hier im deutschen
Rednerpult mehr Steuern und mehr
Steuerbelastung für Unternehmen und
Unternehmen zu fordern die haben nämlich
das Vermögen in den Betrieben und
ähnliches ist quasi gefährlich zu
glauben man konnte so vermögen
Ungleichheit zu bekämpfen man muss die
Debatte vielleicht mal anders
herumführen nämlich die Frage zu stellen
wieso haben eigentlich so wenig Menschen
mit einem mittleren Einkommen Rücklagen
für diese Krise wieso haben sie in den
letzten Jahren kein Vermögen gebildet
wieso ist es in Deutschland so schwer
möglich in den letzten Jahren sich das
Traum den Traum von den iPhone den
eigenen vier Wänden zu ermöglichen also
wir sollten weniger darüber diskutieren
vermeintlich große Vermögen kleiner zu
machen sondern mittlere Einkommen zu
Vermögensbildung aufzurufen ist auch
eine Frage der Nachhaltigkeit und der
Bekämpfung von vermögensungleichheiten
die Debatte andersherum zu führen und
viele junge Menschen machen das die
wissen dass das Rentensystem marode ist
für sie wir Zuschuss und ist schon mit
100 Milliarden 100 Milliarden Euro
Steuergelder fließen jedes Jahr ins
Rentensystem und wir wissen dass die
Demografie das noch weiter verschärfen
wird deswegen sparen junger Menschen in
ETF deswegen legen sie in Aktien ein und
wir sollten ihn Anreize schaffen
beispielsweise durch keine
Spekulationsfrist das auf einer
Haltedauer von 10 20 Jahren man auch
steuerfrei rauskommt große
gesparfheitsfreibeträge also die Frage
von Nachhaltigkeit erschöpft sich nicht
nur in einer ökologischen Dimension oder
in linker Träumerei wo man seinen
Wahlprogramm immer wieder vorliest
sondern es ist notwendig eine vertiefte
Debatte zu führen als FDP stehen wir für
Vermögensaufbau wir stehen für
Aufstiegschancen und das werden wir in
dieser Koalition auch stark machen
vielen Dank
Jens teutrine mit sozialen und
sozialpolitischen Dimensionen des Themas
Nachhaltigkeit und er ist ja auch
Mitglied eben parlamentarischen Beirat
für nachhaltige Entwicklung genauso wie
Jakob Blankenburg aus der SPD-Fraktion
der jetzt spricht liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen die Klimakrise artenkrise
Hungerkrise Energiekrise soziale
Ungleichheit wir haben jetzt von diesem
redepult aus schon viel gehört über die
vielschichtigen Krisen vor denen wir in
Deutschland aber vor denen wir auch als
gesamte Weltgemeinschaft stehen und
manche dieser Krisen die haben ihre
Wurzeln im angriffskriegs Russlands auf
die Ukraine andere die waren schon lange
da und ihre Effekte wurden durch den
Krieg noch mal verstärkt das gilt ganz
im besonderen Maße aber für die
Klimakrise und die nur schleppende
Umstellung der Energieversorgung von
fossilen auf erneuerbare Energie und
diese Klimakrise die trifft uns alle
aber ganz im speziellen die junge
Generation sie ist gleich doppelt
betroffen von dieser Klimakrise sie muss
zum einen besonders lange mit den
negativen Auswirkungen des Klimawandels
zurechtkommen und sie ist zum anderen
aus Sicht der Wissenschaft die letzte
Generation die noch in der Lage ist das
Ruder herumzureißen sie ist gleichsam
dazu verdammt will sie ihren zukünftigen
Lebensgrundlagen schützen und wo immer
man hinschaut da drängen deshalb junge
Menschen auch Veränderungen sei es beim
globalen klimastreik am vergangenen
Freitag sein ist die Eingaben der
jung-deligierten beim high-level
political forum on substanable
Development vergangenen Sommer in New
York oder die Beiträge der
Jugendverbände wir haben es heute schon
gehört bei der Jahrestagung des Rates
für nachhaltige Entwicklung am Montag
überall sind sich die jungen Menschen
einig das zu wenig passiert und dass wir
als Politikerinnen und Politiker zu
langsam sind
auch der Identifikation
identifikatorenbericht 2021 der über den
Sachstand der Erreichung der Ziele für
nachhaltige Entwicklung Auskunft gibt
der zeigt für Deutschland ein eher
ausbaufähiges Bild bei zentralen
Entwicklungszielen oder kurz scgs wie
Armut Hunger oder Ungleichheit da treten
wir auf der Stelle oder haben uns sogar
verschlechtert und dabei läuft uns die
Zeit davon wir haben nur noch acht Jahre
zu Erreichung der Ziele der Agenda 2030
und wir müssen uns jetzt bewegen
und liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen beim
Thema erneuerbare Energien der zeigen
wir aktuell dass das geht dass wir Tempo
machen können wir stellen die Weichen
für einen beschleunigten Ausbau der
Erneuerbaren und damit hin zu einer
klimaneutralen nachhaltigen
Energieerzeugung
aber wir müssen wir müssen das in mehr
Bereichen schaffen deutschland und die
anderen westlichen Industriestaaten
steht die stehen in der Verantwortung
beim Thema nachhaltige Entwicklung
voranzugehen wir haben unseren Wohlstand
zum Teil zu Lasten anderer Länder
aufgebaut ganz zu schweigen welchen
negativen Umweltauswirkungen unserer
wirtschaften und handeln bis heute hat
und blickt man auf die Auswirkungen der
eingangsgenannten Krisen dann stellen
die westlichen Entwicklung
Industriestaaten im Vergleich zu vielen
Schwellenländern und Entwicklungsländern
vergleichsweise gut da und deshalb
dürfen wir bei der Umsetzung von Klima
und Entwicklungszielen nicht nachlassen
ganz im Gegenteil wir müssen weiter
vorangehen und Vorbild sein auch um
andere Länder zu ambitionierte rapolitik
zu bewegen
und deshalb
liegt Kolleginnen und Kollegen ist es
wichtig dass sich die aktuelle
Regierungskoalition als
fortschrittskoalition zum Thema
Nachhaltigkeit bekennt und sie bekennt
sich zu internationaler Zusammenarbeit
und zu Bewältigung globaler Krisen das
haben wir heute morgen auch schon von
entwicklungsministerin Schulze gehört
das hat Bundeskanzler oder Scholz auch
nochmals bei der UN-Generalversammlung
unterstrichen im Rahmen der Deutschen
g7-präsidentschaft haben wir uns auch
ganz konkret unter Beweis gestellt und
das Bündnis für Ernährungssicherheit und
den klimaklub initiiert
und liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen auch
wir als Bundestag wir bekennen uns zum
Thema Nachhaltigkeit und deshalb müssen
wir als Parlament den Anspruch haben bei
Weichenstellungen in der Nachhaltigkeit
auch mit am Tisch zu sitzen wir haben
bislang den parlamentarischen Beirat für
nachhaltige Entwicklung als unser
Gremium dafür aber wie der Name schon
sagt hat das Gremium ein er begleitende
und beratenden Charakter hier müssen wir
uns als Parlament stärker einbringen und
ein wesentlichen zu entscheidensgremium
auf ein wesentliches wirkliches
Entscheidungsgremium hinwirken wie das
konkret aussehen kann das wird uns als
Deutscher Bundestag in den nächsten
Monaten beschäftigen kommt nicht zum
Schluss der hat uns auch heute schon
Vorschläge unterbreitet und ich komme
zum Schluss liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen ich freue mich auf die Debatte
dazu dass wir als Parlament wirklich ein
Wachhund mit zehn im Bereich der
Nachhaltigkeit werden daran arbeiten wir
in den nächsten Monaten vielen Dank
Jakob Blankenburg ob man im
parlamentarischen Beirat für nachhaltige
Entwicklung für den er mehr Kompetenzen
eingefordert hat das haben wir heute
schon öfter mal gehört hier im Bundestag
hat Yvonne Marc was die Sitzungsleitung
übernommen die
Bundestagsvizepräsidentin der Bundestag
diskutiert noch bis ca 12:30 Uhr über
die nationale Nachhaltigkeitsstrategie
und dazu ist jetzt am Pult Astrid
Damerow ob Frau im Ausschuss für Umwelt
und Naturschutz und Mitglied der
Unionsfraktion
frau Präsidentin sehr geehrte
Kolleginnen und Kollegen ja es ist gut
dass wir die Nachhaltigkeit bei
politischen Entscheidungen in den
vergangenen Jahrzehnten deutlich mehr
berücksichtigt haben aber gerade in der
Umwelt Landwirtschaft und
ernährungspolitik wird dabei auch
deutlich wie sehr diese Ziele sich
teilweise oder wie sehr diese Ziele
teilweise in einem Konflikt zueinander
stehen
beispielsweise fordert das Ziel Nummer
sechs Wasser für alle verfügbar zu
machen und
das Ziel 15 den der Schutz der
Landökosysteme
diese beiden
also Ziel Nummer sechs und Ziel Nummer
15 Schutz des Wassers und Schutz der
Landökosysteme sind ein
nachhaltigkeitsziel den wir uns
verpflichtet haben seit Jahren
unternehmen wir sehr viel um unsere
Gewässer zu schützen und unsere
ökologische Vielfalt zu erhalten und zu
verbessern alle Programme dazu fordern
aber auch beispielsweise unserer
Landwirtschaft eine Menge ab damit sind
wir beim nachhaltigkeitsziel 2 der
Ernährungssicherheit
Deutschland ist ein Kunststandort für
die Nahrungsmittelproduktion soll heißen
wir haben auch die Pflicht
Nahrungsmittel für Menschen in weniger
begünstigten begünstigten Regionen der
Erde zu produzieren heißt also zwischen
den Nachhaltigkeitszielen Schutz des
Wassers und der Land Ökosysteme und dem
Ziel Nummer zwei der
Ernährungssicherheit bestehen nicht
unerhebliche Konflikte die wir erstens
finde ich in den Debatten um unsere
Schutzprogramme deutlich klarer benennen
müssen
bei denen wir aber auch alles an
Innovationen nutzen müssen um diese
Ziele zu erreichen ich spreche hier mal
beispielsweise an die Debatte die wir
vor einiger Zeit hatten zur Nutzung
neuer genomischer Techniken zu Züchtung
von landwirtschaftlichen Nutzpflanzen
ein anderes Beispiel ist das SDS Nummer
9 hier bekennen wir uns zu einer
widerstandsfähigen Infrastruktur und im
Ziel Nummer 11 zu sicheren und wieder zu
sicheren und widerstandsfähigen Städten
und Siedlung
verschiedene Hochwasserkatastrophen in
den vergangenen Jahren für uns aber
führen uns aber vor Augen dass wir
massive staatliche Investitionen in den
Hochwasserschutz vornehmen müssen ein
widerstandsfähiger Hochwasserschutz wird
aber auch Flächen in Anspruch nehmen
dies sind dann Flächen die wir nur noch
eingeschränkt für Siedlungen für
Landwirtschaft aber auch für den Ausbau
der erneuerbaren Energien nutzen können
haben wir für diese Konflikte wirklich
schon antworten
im nachhaltigkeitsziel Nummer 14
fordern wir die nachhaltig die
nachhaltige Nutzung und Bewahrung
unserer Ozeane und Meere natürlich sie
sind Lebensraum für Fische Vögel
Pflanzen und sie sind unverzichtbar für
das Überleben der Menschheit das auch
deshalb hat Deutschland 45 Prozent
seiner Meeresgewässer unter Schutz
gestellt unsere Meere sind aber auch
Wirtschaftsräume für Fischerei für
Tourismus sie sind Handelswege es sind
Häfen die notwendig sind eben für den
Transport von Waren und Gütern
zusätzlich werden wir nun mit der
Offshore-Energie auch noch mehr
erneuerbare Energien auch in unseren
Meeren produzieren müssen denn die
Produktion von erneuerbaren Energien ist
ein Beitrag zum nachhaltigkeitsziel
Nummer 7 nachhaltige und moderne Energie
für alle zur Verfügung zu stellen
zugleich ist der Bau von
offshorwindanlagen aber ein massiver
Eingriff in das wir Ökosystem in unserer
Niere auch auf diese Konfliktsituation
brauchen wir Antworten die wir
ehrlicherweise noch nicht haben
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen diese
Beispiele belegen dass alle
Nachhaltigkeitsziele sich aufeinander
beziehen das ist heute schon
angesprochen worden soll heißen dass das
vollständige Erreichen eines
nachhaltigkeitszieles sofort massive
Konflikte mit dem Erreichen anderer
Ziele nach sich zie
HT um das in Einklang zu bringen
wird uns viel abverlangt werden wir
werden wesentlich offener das hat die
Kollegin der FDP vorhin angesprochen wir
werden viel offener uns mit Innovationen
in allen Bereichen beschäftigen müssen
es darf dann auch keine Denkverbote
geben die wir alle zugegebenermaßen
mitunter auch reflexhaft haben ich hatte
vorhin schon das Thema der genomischen
Techniken angesprochen
ich denke die Debatte um die
Nachhaltigkeit wird immer wieder auch
wirklich zu politischen
Auseinandersetzungen führen und zwar
hier in unserem Parlament das ist
richtig und das ist auch wichtig und ich
will mich hier meinem Kollegen Ralf
Brinkhaus anschließen ich hätte mir sehr
gewünscht dass auch diese
nordjas die Ampelkoalition wie in der
Vergangenheit auch sich dafür wirklich
einen ganzen Tag Zeit genommen hätte und
jeder Fachbereich das Thema
Nachhaltigkeit hätte ausgiebig
diskutieren können denn
an den
an den wenigen Beispielen die ich gerade
aufgezählt habe wird ja deutlich dass es
wirklich sehr sehr komplex ist in allen
Fachbereichen und wir werden eigentlich
mit einer Debatte von drei Stunden der
Komplexität dieses Themas in keiner
Weise gerecht also möglicherweise ist
die Ampelkoalition in der Lage sich
vielleicht für nächstes Jahr ein anderes
Vorgehen zu überlegen das würde meine
Fraktion und mich sehr freuen vielen
Dank für Ihre Aufmerksamkeit
auch Astrid demmerow aus der
Unionsfraktion beklagt noch einmal das
die Zeit für diese
Nachhaltigkeitsdebatte doch einigermaßen
übersichtlich bemessen ist sie ist zwar
für eine Debatte mit drei Stunden oder
fast dreieinhalb durchaus lang und
länger als hier der übliche Durchschnitt
aber wie gesagt zu Beginn der letzten
Legislaturperiode wurde sehr viel
intensiver über das Thema Nachhaltigkeit
diskutiert und dann auch zu den
einzelnen Ressorts der damaligen
Bundesregierung Stefan gelb war Fraktion
Bündnis 90 die Grünen Istanbul gefragt
ob die letzten Worte wir werden das für
das nächste Jahr sicherlich
berücksichtigen aber ich möchte mal eins
sagen erstens 2020 2019 2021 war das
eben auch keine nachhaltigkeitswoche wie
der Kollege Ralf Brinkhaus angesprochen
hat ist einfach nicht passiert und es
ist auch ehrlich gesagt nicht so dass
wir eine Erkenntnis oder wissensproblem
haben wir haben Umsetzungsprobleme und
und noch einen Schritt durch ich bin
noch eins sagen Richtung des Kollegen
Brinkhaus sie haben so wunderbar
formuliert ist immer mal was anderes
wichtiger ja das ist ja aber nicht von
Himmel gefallen sondern das sind ja
menschengemachte Entscheidung dass immer
etwas anderes wichtiger war und für
diese Entscheidung gab es
Verantwortlichkeiten und gerade die
größte Fraktion der letzten Legislatur
hat doch da irgendeine Verantwortung
gehabt und ehrlich gesagt auch der
Fraktionsvorsitzende der größten
Fraktion hat doch damit Verantwortung
deswegen bin ich ehrlich gesagt ein
bisschen irritiert wenn sich hier nach
vorne stellen und sagen alles wann
andere war irgendwie ein bisschen
wichtiger sorry für das deswegen sind
wir nicht so richtig Weiterkommen aber
jetzt noch mal richtig loslegen das ist
ehrlich gesagt aus einem raus und
breiter auch benennen das passt nicht
aber gut
Vergangenheit ist alles Vergangenheit
aber trotzdem man muss es doch mal
einmal immer mal wieder andeuten wenn
das hier so vorgetragen wird aber
nochmal konkret Nachhaltigkeit und
Verkehr das erste Stichwort dazu ist ja
Klimaschutz und hier haben wir
Nachholbedarf nach vielen Jahren und
Jahrzehnten der Untätigkeit wir hoffen
dass da der Verkehrsminister im Rahmen
des Klimaschutz Sofortprogramms jetzt
ein Maßnahmenpaket vorliegen wird und
das ist mit der Erwartung verbunden von
uns zumindest dass das dann den
Klimaschutzzielen von Paris genügt nach
einem Jahr Ampelkoalition ist sehr
Koalitionsvertrag logischerweise noch
nicht abgearbeitet damit aber unsere
künftige Verkehrspolitik klimagerecht
ist brauchen wir dem vereinbarten
klimaschek und das ist eine Aufgabe die
muss jetzt kommen
aber Nachhaltigkeit das ist ja nicht die
ganzen Redebeiträge schon durchgeklungen
ist eben nicht nur Klimaschutz sondern
zum Beispiel auch Umweltschutz und auch
hier hat der Verkehrssektor erheblichen
Nachholbedarf der Straßenbau der
verbraucht Fläche Wälder werden
abgeholzt Moore werden trockengelegt
Lebensräume von Wildtieren werden
zerschnitten deswegen haben wir auch
etwas im Koalitionsvertrag festgehalten
nämlich den Flächenverbrauch stark
einzudämmen und das gilt es nun in die
Arbeit der Ministerien in die Arbeit des
Verkehrsministeriums zu implementieren
und das betrifft dann zum Beispiel den
Straßen neu und Ausbau da müssen wir da
werden wir reduzieren müssen
und ganz ehrlich wenn es jetzt
da gibt es auch gar nicht so viel
Widerspruch das ist auch logisch weil
vier Fraktionen der hier versammelten
Fraktionen haben dem auch schon mal 2010
zugestimmt im Rahmen der onet wo ich
stand und Wachstum Wachstum und
Ruhestand da ist gesagt worden wir
müssen Reduktionsziele da immer wieder
nachschauen und eben umsetzen wir müssen
weg von diesem Sonntag sehen schließlich
nachhaltig Verkehrspolitik
berücksichtigt den Gesundheitsschutz da
geht es um Lärm da geht es um Feinstaub
und Stickoxide um Ruß und da haben wir
nicht nur eine globale Verantwortung
sondern auch eine soziale und ehrlich
gesagt
und deswegen will ich das zum Schluss
vielleicht sagen wir haben im
Koalitionsvertrag auch in
gleichstellungscheck und der wird auch
sich das genau anschauen das ist wichtig
und last but not least weil die FDP
anderen was ab ja wir müssen wegkommen
von den drastischen Fehlern reizen da
haben die Kollegen von der FDP Recht und
deswegen müssen wir klimaschädliche
Subventionen aufbauen und doch das ist
der Ziel unser vorsichtig vielen Dank
stefan gelper am Ende noch mit einer
Ermahnung von Bundestagsvizepräsidentin
Marc was seine Redezeit angeht er hat
unter anderem den Klima-Check erwähnt
der im Koalitionsvertrag festgehalten
ist und der alle Gesetze über mit dem
alle Gesetze überprüft werden sollten
das ganze ist nach wie vor ihnen Arbeit
und eben Wirtschaftsministerium das
ohnehin gerade gut beschäftigt ist
Stefan Brandner für die afd-fraktion
Nachhaltigkeitsstrategie gibt seit 2017
die nationale Nachhaltigkeitsstrategie
seit 2002 die nationale
Nachhaltigkeitsstrategie seit 2002 erst
Schröder dann Merkel jetzt Scholz mit
seiner hellbraunen Truppe meine Damen
und Herren was daraus geworden bisher
nichts ich bin jetzt der 26 Redner in
dieser Debatte 22 Mal haben wir bisher
heiße klimaschädliche altparteienluft
gehört warum frage ich mich ich sage
Ihnen warum das ist ja 20 Jahren in der
Nachhaltigkeit herumstochern
nachhaltigkeitssumpf sich herumwuseln
und es hat zu nichts geführt der
bisherige Erfolg ihrer Nachhaltigkeit
ist sie haben Deutschland nachhaltig
geschadet sie haben Deutschland
nachhaltig ruiniert unser Deutschland
steht nachhaltig am Abgrund und zwar von
diesem Abgrund nicht mehr weit entfernt
und wenn sie nachhaltig so weitermachen
dann sind wir demnächst einen Schritt
weiter nämlich im Abgrund nachhaltig die
Armut meine Damen und Herren nimmt
rasant zu die Inflation galoppiert die
Verbraucher und Energiepreise
explodieren wir sind
verteidigungsunfähig wir sind bei
Energie Pharmazie
IT und lebensmittelabhängig vom Ausland
das ist der Erfolg ihrer
Nachhaltigkeitsstrategie seit 20 Jahren
meine Leute ich sage Ihnen was wir
brauchen wir brauchen eine nachhaltige
Umsetzung des afd-programms die brauchen
wir und nichts anderes wir stehen für
wir stehen für die Existenz unseres
Deutschlands für beschlossene Grenzen
und die Beendigung der
illegalen Einwanderung wir stehen für
ein Leben dass man sich leisten kann für
Energiesicherheit und
Versorgungssicherheit für Wohlstand und
die Stärkung der Wirtschaft wir stehen
für Grundrechte für Freiheit die
demokratischen Prinzipien für
Gewaltenteilung die Freiheit der Meinung
die Demonstrationsfreiheit für eine
freie Presse und für die freie
Entfaltung der Persönlichkeit wir stehen
schlicht und ergreifend dafür unser
Deutschland unser Land zuerst vielen
Dank
und für die FDP-Fraktion hat das Wort
Rio Schröder Ria Schröder
ist bildungspolitische Sprecherin der
FDP-Fraktion
für die Wichtigkeit von Bildung Bedarf
hätte dann haben sie den eben erbracht
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen sehr verehrte
Damen und Herren auf der Tribüne Bildung
ist das Thema meiner Rede denn das
vierte nachhaltigkeitsziel das ist nicht
zufällig inklusive gerechte und
hochwertige Bildung zu gewährleisten und
Möglichkeiten des lebenslangen Lernens
für alle zu fördern Bildung schafft
Chancen für ein selbstbestimmtes Leben
und sie ist die Voraussetzung für
zukunftsweisende Wissenschaft und
Forschung dank wissenschaftlicher
Erkenntnisse kennen wir etwa denen
Zusammenhang zwischen dem Ausstoß von
CO2 und dem Klimawandel dank Forschung
und Innovation können wir nachhaltige
Alternativen zu forcieren Lebensweise
entwickeln das Bundesministerium für
Bildung und Forschung treibt als
zentraler nachhaltigkeitsakteur diese
Entwicklung voran sei es mit grünem
Wasserstoff in der nationalen
wasserstoffstrategie oder bei
Zukunftstechnologien für übermorgen
beispielsweise bei der
Grundlagenforschung im Bereich der
Kernfusion bei mir liegt das Fundament
für unsere nachhaltige klimaneutrale und
souveräne Zukunft
[Applaus]
Bildung und Forschung sind die Antwort
auf die multiplen Krisen die wir derzeit
erleben Inflation ist eine der größten
Bedrohungen für den Wohlstand in unserem
Land und wenn das Ersparte auf dem Konto
oder im Sparstrumpf immer weniger wert
ist dann trifft das ganz besonders
Menschen die nur wenig Geld zur
Verfügung haben bei denen es auf jeden
Euro ankommt und gleichzeitig ist es so
dass viele Menschen gar nicht richtig
wissen wie ihnen geschieht Inflation
Finanzmarkt Bankenwesen böhmische Dörfer
für so viele in unserem Land und dafür
daher ist ökonomische Bildung
finanzielle Alphabetisierung
entscheidend meine Damen und Herren es
geht um nicht weniger als um die
Demokratisierung von elitenwissen machen
wir unser Wirtschaftssystem für alle
Menschen zugänglich in dem das Wissen
darüber bereits in der Schule
unterrichtet wird junge Menschen sollten
Ahnung haben von Aktien und ETFs sie
sollten verstehen wie man Unternehmen
gründet und wie man wie man für das
Alter vorsorgt Jungen und Mädchen in
allen Schulformen
ganz besonders für Mädchen ist die
finanzielle Bildung wichtig denn gerade
beim Thema Altersvorsorge sehen wir das
immer wieder besonders Frauen sind von
Altersarmut betroffen und es ist ein
Realität da brauchen sie die ganze Zeit
hier nicht so rumblöcken von der Seite
im Koalitionsvertrag haben wir bewusst
festgehalten dass wir Schülerfirmen als
Bestandteil von Bildung für nachhaltige
Entwicklung fördern wollen denn
ökonomische Bildung und Nachhaltigkeit
das gehört zusammen meine Damen und
Herren Bildung und Forschung machen
unsere Gesellschaft zukunftsfähig die
Menschen frei und unsere Demokratie
stark und was könnte nachhaltiger sein
Bildung Forschung und Innovation sind
drei Punkte in den
Nachhaltigkeitszielen die wiederum zur
Nachhaltigkeitsstrategie gehören aber
auch nachhaltiges Wirtschaften gehört
dazu insofern passend jetzt dabeitrag
von Bernd Westphal dem
wirtschaftspolitischen Sprecher der
spd-fraktionen
haben das ist wirklich Unsinn und
Schwachsinn und ich will Ihnen ja nur
mal sagen Humboldt hat schon gesagt die
Weltanschauung derer ist sehr gefährlich
die sich die Welt nie angeschaut haben
sie sind betriebsprinzip werden mit
einer großen Mehrheit in diesem Volk nie
in der Lage sein dass sie dieses Land
regieren oder führen sie ertragen
überhaupt gar keinen Beitrag dafür wie
man Zukunft gestaltet
meine sehr verehrten Damen und Herren
Nachhaltigkeit ja merkt schon dass das
trifft im Kern weil sie hier Unsinn nur
verbreiten zurück zum Thema
Nachhaltigkeit ist sehr wichtig und
deshalb ist es gut dass wir diese batte
heute hier im Deutschen Bundestag führen
schon im April 1961 hat Willy Brandt
gesagt in einer Rede in Bonn dass der
Himmel über dem Ruhrgebiet wieder blau
werden muss und schon damals ist erkannt
worden mit Umweltaspekten das
wirtschaftliche Erfolg nur sich
einstellen kann wenn man auch genau
diese Aspekte mit berücksichtigt damals
ist schon erkannt worden
frau Präsidentin darf ich meine Rede
fortführen Dankeschön es ist nur damit
sind tumultschleier möglich und
damals ist schon erkannt worden mit
einer Umweltbewegung des wirtschaftliche
Erfolg nur dann einstellbar ist wenn man
auch die sozialen und ökologischen
Aspekte mit berücksichtigen und deshalb
sage ich unsere Volkswirtschaft ist
nicht trotz sondern wegen hohen
Umweltschutzstandards wegen hohen
Sozialstandards wirtschaftlich
erfolgreich und das ist die Grundlage
für wirtschaftlichen Erfolg
es ist viel passiert es ist schon viel
passiert wenn man sich die Berichte der
Unternehmen anguckt und zwar nicht nur
die Finanzkennzahlen sondern die
Nachhaltigkeitsberichte die in den
letzten Jahren immer umfangreicher
geworden sind die beschreiben wo
Unternehmen sich auf den Weg gemacht
haben innovative Produkte auf den Weg zu
bringen auch Rohstoffwirtschaft so zu
organisieren in den Lieferketten dass
sie eben den hohen Ansprüchen gerecht
werden und dass wir in eine
Kreislaufwirtschaft kommen wo wir auch
Produkte aus der Industrie
wiederverwenden für neue Technologien
und das ist etwas an dem wir weiter auch
uns über Politik orientieren der
Koalitionsvertrag mit fair Fortschritt
Wagen mit mehr innovationenwagen ist
genau das Ziel dass wir das 1,5 Grad
Ziel erreichen wollen dieser
Koalitionsvertrag ist wie ein roter
Faden orientiert daran wie man diese
Ziele erreichen kann und deshalb sage
ich wir haben mit unserer Wirtschaft mit
unserem Mittelstand und Industrie nicht
das Problem sondern die Lösung für
globale Herausforderungen gerade aus der
Industrie gerade aus den Laboren aus den
Werkstätten verbunden mit Universitäten
und dieses innovative Umfeld wird dazu
führen dass wir neue
Exportmöglichkeiten entwickeln globale
Märkte erschließen für Produkte aus
deutschen Produktion und das wird auch
helfen diese Klimaziele zu erreichen
wenn man sich mal anguckt wie wir
Investitionen gestalten ist es
sicherlich notwendig auch staatlich zu
unterstützen viele Programme Tim und
andere aus dem Wirtschaftsministerium
ermuntern ja gerade den Mittelstand
diese Innovationen nach vorne zu bringen
aber ich sage auch die Rahmenbedingungen
für private Investitionen müssen wir
verbessern auch in die Infrastruktur
unseres Landes wir müssen moderner
werden im Gesundheitswesen in der
Infrastruktur das was erneuerbare
Energien angeht Wasserstofftechnologie
aber auch die Glasfasernetze das wird
die Zukunft sein auf der sich
wirtschaftliche Entwicklung gut
entfalten kann
sehr verehrten Damen und Herren Willy
Brandt hat auch gesagt dass wir als
reiche Länder eine Verantwortung haben
auch gegenüber der südlichen Halbkugel
in
ärmeren Ländern Schwellenländern und das
was Willy Brandt mit Olaf Palm auf den
Weg gebracht hat den Nord-Süd-Dialog das
ist auch getragen von einer
Verantwortung eines reichen Landes wir
müssen auch dafür sorgen dass wir die
sozialen Aspekte global verankern es
kann nicht sein dass wir mit Hunger mit
Armut mit Kindersterblichkeit des
zulassen wie andere Menschen in anderen
Regionen leben müssen letzter Satz frau
Präsidentin ich finde auch die sozialen
Aspekte müssen wir hier in Deutschland
in den Betrieben uns noch mal angucken
wie wir Mitbestimmung beteiligen zum
Schluss Verteidigung der Belegschaft
auch erweitern können auch in den Themen
der Nachhaltigkeit des Klima vielen Dank
während Westphal wirtschaftspolitische
Sprecher der SPD-Fraktion in der Debatte
über die deutsche
Nachhaltigkeitsstrategie nächster Redner
Andreas Lenz cdu/csu-fraktion
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrte Damen und Herren liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen das Ziel einer
nachhaltigen Entwicklung ist gerade auch
jetzt wichtig und schaut mal auf die
Welt dann bestätigt sich doch diese
Einschätzung und insofern können die 14
Nachhaltigkeitsziele die auf Ebene der
Vereinten Nationen beschlossen wurden
beispielsweise keine Armut Ziel eins
Ziel zwei kein Hunger gute Bildung C4
Gleichberechtigung der Geschlechter C5
bis hin zufrieden Gerechtigkeit starke
Institutionen gerade jetzt und auch im
internationalen Kontext nicht stark
genug betont werden gerade jetzt ist
eine nachhaltige Entwicklung wichtig
meine Damen und Herren und jetzt wissen
wir alle gerade in Krisenzeiten spricht
man nicht so gerne über Themen wie
Nachhaltigkeit weil an mancher glaubt
das wäre jetzt nicht so wichtig es ist
auch übrigens schade dass die zuständige
Staatsministerin niklewski der Debatte
nicht mehr beiwohnt aber ich möchte aber
ich möchte ganz klar sagen dass
Gegenteil ist doch der Fall es geht bei
Fragen einer nachhaltigen Entwicklung
auch darum Krisen in der Zukunft zu
verhindern viele schwerwiegende Krisen
der heutigen Zeit sind sogenannte
systemische Krisen Pandemien Klimakrise
Finanzkrisen Krisen der
Energieversorgung Stichwort Gefahren
eines Blackouts lieferkettenprobleme
internationale Abhängigkeiten und so
weiter und das heißt es sind immer
anfällige Gesamtsysteme oft sehr
verwundbar oft auch im globalen Kontext
stehen und deshalb bedeutet nachhaltige
Entwicklung immer auch ein mehr an
Resilienz an mehr an
Widerstandsfähigkeit ins System damit
auch ein mehr an Souveränität und zwar
in jedem Bereich bei der
Nahrungsmittelversorgung bei der Frage
der medizinischen Erzeugnisse aber auch
bei der Frage von gewissen
einsatzprodukten für unsere Wirtschaft
bei der Frage von Mikrochips bei
Lieferketten mehr Widerstandsfähigkeit
auch durch stabile Staatsfinanzen und
damit mehr Stabilität für die sozialen
Sicherungssysteme und natürlich auch
mehr
Generationengerechtigkeit und für diese
Stabilität für diese
Widerstandsfähigkeit stehen wir als
Union und das haben wir in unserem
Antrag auch sehr deutlich gemacht um das
klar zu sagen
wir stehen zu einer nachhaltigen
heimischen Landwirtschaft die wiederum
für Ernährungssicherheit steht und dazu
beiträgt und wir wollen im Kontext der
Ernährungssicherheit übrigens explizit
rechts und Sicherheiten bei der
kostenlosen Weitergabe von Lebensmitteln
abbauen es ist ja nach wie vor ein
Skandal das 11 Millionen Tonnen
Lebensmittel in den im Abfall landen das
pro Person 78 Kilogramm Nahrungsmittel
im Abfall landen und da muss weiter
dagegen gearbeitet werden wir stehen
außerdem für Regionalität für Lokalität
wir brauchen eine neue Balance zwischen
Internationalität
internationalen Arbeitsteilung die in
keiner Weise in Frage zu stellen ist und
Regionalität Produkte aus der Region
sind ein Megatrend mit vielen Chancen
mit vielen Wertschöpfungsmöglichkeiten
und wir haben in einer Aktion am
Dienstag als Unionsfraktion eben auch
diese Vielfalt aus den Regionen sehr gut
dargestellt sie werden außerdem dazu
beitragen diese regionalen Produkte
tragen dazu bei Transportwege zu sparen
zum Nutzen aller wir werden Regionalität
regionale Produkte weiter stärken meine
Damen und Herren
und gerade im Moment zeigt sich doch
auch an vielen Stellen wir können nur
helfen auch international wenn wir
wirtschaftlich stark sind wenn wir
leistungsfähig bleiben wir können auch
nur dann technologischen Transfer
übrigens leisten wenn unsere Technologie
wenn wir unsere Technologie auch im
eigenen Land anwenden und wenn sie dann
auch entsprechend entsprechend
erfolgreich international sind wie
wichtig die ökonomische Dimension ist
das erleben wir doch gerade jetzt auch
im Sinne der Energieversorgung wir
brauchen hier auch alle Dimensionen wir
brauchen natürlich die ökologische
Dimension wir brauchen mehr Erneuerbaren
wir müssen auch systemisch denken wir
brauchen Versorgungssicherheit wir
brauchen aber auch bei der
Energieversorgung die wirtschaftliche
die ökonomische Perspektive die
Dimension dass wir auch entsprechend
wettbewerbsfähige Preise brauchen für
unsere Wirtschaft und wir müssen
natürlich auch die soziale Dimension
entsprechend berücksichtigen dass sich
jeder auch die Energieversorgung
entsprechend leisten muss wir brauchen
diese Voraussetzungen sonst eine
Dimension entsprechend auch die
ökonomische im gesamten in
Mitleidenschaft gezogen zu werden und
verschwindet die Industrie verschwindet
das produzierende Gewerbe in Deutschland
dann gibt es auch nichts mehr zu
transformieren hin zu einer
klimaneutralen Wirtschaft das müssen wir
immer auch entsprechend im Hinterkopf
haben
verschwindet die Industrie aus
Deutschland das sind aber die Emissionen
nicht weg die Emissionen finden dann an
anderen Orten der Welt statt und das ist
eben gerade nicht nachhaltig manchmal
kann man sich den Begriff der
Nachhaltigkeit übrigens auch nähern wenn
man davon ausgeht was nicht nachhaltig
ist ein Beispiel das eben zeigt dass
Nachhaltigkeit nur funktioniert wenn
alle Dimensionen entsprechend
berücksichtigt werden und das
Nachhaltigkeit immer auch immer auch
eine globale Perspektive hat der Weg zu
einer nachhaltigen Entwicklung des lang
wir sind schon einen guten Weg gegangen
und es ist aus meiner aus unserer Sicht
alle Mühe wert diesen Weg entsprechend
weiterzugehen und dabei müssen wir auch
immer wissen dass der Weg hin zu einer
nachhaltigen Entwicklung auch immer ein
Stück ein Weg hinzu einem Mehr an
Nachhaltigkeit eben auch entsprechend
ist und nicht entsprechend in einem Ziel
dann die Erfüllung findet sondern auch
sich entsprechend in diesem Prozess
wiederfindet in diesem Sinne herzlichen
Dank
Andreas Lenz war das aus der
Unionsfraktion und ihm wird jetzt folgen
Caroline Otto sie ist Mitglied im
Ausschuss für Wohnen statt Entwicklung
Bauwesen und Kommunen und sie ahnen es
auch das ein wichtiger Aspekt beim Thema
Nachhaltigkeit und falls ich jetzt aus
Versehen Ortho gesagt habe das ist
falsch
wäre richtig gewesen
es geht um nicht weniger als eine Welt
die Zukunft hat
die Klimakrise das tatsächliche an die
Wand fahren unserer Lebensgrundlage das
kann einem im Plenardebatten vielleicht
reichlich abstrakt vorkommen aber ein
Jahr nach der Katastrophe im Aartal nach
einem Hitzesommer mit krasser Dürre vom
Schwarzwald bis nach Brandenburg
wenn Sie das so sehen ich fand es ganz
schön warm mit den aktuellen Bildern aus
Pakistan es muss doch jetzt überall klar
geworden sein was die Abhängigkeit von
fossilen Energien für unsere
Gesellschaft bedeutet eine Abhängigkeit
die just in diesem Moment als Waffe
gegen uns gerichtet wird die Antwort auf
die Vielzahl dieser Krisen mit denen wir
gerade umgehen müssen die darf nicht der
fossile Rollback sein
der Kampf für eine Welt die Zukunft hat
beginnt vor Ort und er ist
entschlossener zu führen denn je wir
müssen jetzt vor Ort investieren in der
aktuellen Situation auf die
Schuldenbremse zu pochen das ist
gefährlich
der nächste wichtige Schritt die
wärmewende die findet vor Ort statt und
braucht die Bereitschaft des Bundes da
substanziellen Mittel zur Verfügung zu
stellen
den wärmeenergieverbrauch schnell zu
senken das ist das Gebot der Stunde
Städte und Gemeinden arbeiten mit
niedrigschwelligen Maßnahmen schon jetzt
daran und heben ein Effizienzpotenzial
von 20%. damit wir mittel und
langfristig den wärmeenergieverbrauch
senken ist es entscheidend dass wir
energetische Gebäudesanierung verstärkt
fördern mit dem Gebäude Energiegesetz
wird außerdem dafür gesorgt dass 65
Prozent Erneuerbare erneuerbare Wärme
und der KFW 40 Standard für den Neubau
zum Standardwerten
[Applaus]
damit wir sicherstellen dass alle
Haushalte eine Alternative zu fossil
betriebenen Heizsystemen haben brauchen
wir die kommunale wärmeplanung hier
füllen wir die wärmewende vor Ort mit
leben
mit der kommunalen wärmeplanung bringen
wir ein Projekt des Koalitionsvertrages
auf dem Weg das zentrale ist für die
Bewältigung der wärmebände wir brauchen
vor Ort die Mittel und das Personal ein
guter Antworten gemeinsam mit den
Menschen entwickeln zu können wisst und
das Dorf hinein aus dem ich komme
brauchen wir gute Lösungen
flächendeckend und verschränkt mit dem
systementwicklungsplan des
Wirtschaftsministeriums wir brauchen die
Städte und Gemeinden für eine Welt die
Zukunft hat brauchen wir starke Kommunen
und für die afd-fraktion hat das Wort dr
Dirk Spaniel
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrte Damen und Herren liebe Kollegen
meine Uhr läuft nicht
alles gut so also fange ich schon mal an
ja meine Damen und Herren wir haben die
Nachhaltigkeitsdebatte hier diese
Nachhaltigkeitsdebatte die wir jetzt
hier stundenlang hören zeigt uns vor
allen Dingen dass sie nicht interessiert
sind an echten Lösungen sondern vor
allen Dingen daran interessiert sind
hier Phrasen Reden zu halten und
Menschen zu beeindrucken mit leeren
Versprechungen und jetzt komme ich mal
konkret was haben sie für Gesetze
gemacht sie haben ja die Gesetze gemacht
die letzten Jahre nicht wir sie haben
ein Gesetz gemacht nachdem ein im
Verkehrssektor jetzt mal davon zu reden
geht es ja immer um die Reduktion von
CO2-Emissionen und das ist ihr größtes
Ziel und sie haben ein Gesetz gemacht
mit dem Elektroautos die mit Kohlestrom
geladen werden
ein CO2-Ausstoß erzeugen der doppelt so
groß ist wie der von heutigen
dieselbetriebenen Kraftfahrzeugen
doppelt so groß das können wir hier
machen das ist ihr Gesetz dass sie
gemacht haben auf europäischer Ebene
dagegen wollen Sie verhindern dass die
Besitzer von verbrennungsmotorischen
Autos mit co2-neutralem Sprit und gar
keine Emissionen erzeugen dass diese als
nachhaltig eingestuft werden das ist
ihre konkrete Gesetzgebung und das ist
nicht nachhaltig das ist einfach nur
Unsinn und das führt auch dazu dass die
Arbeitsplätze in unserem Land verloren
gehen und dass die Gleichheit in unserem
Land die wir ja immer anstreben dass
manche Menschen sich Mobilität mit Autos
leisten können und andere nicht was die
verloren geht es wird in unserem Land
dazu führen dass nur noch sehr wenige
Menschen sich Mobilität leisten können
weil viele nämlich auch gar kein
Arbeitsplatz mehr haben weil die
Elektroautos die sie die sie so gerne
wollen die kommen gar nicht aus
Deutschland
und das ist ganz anders als die
Nachhaltigkeit die wir uns als Partei
vorstellen wir wollen auch
Nachhaltigkeit wir wollen genau die 17
Development Goals die sie auch haben
aber mit anderen Methoden wir wollen
nicht ihre Phrasen nachziehen wir wollen
dass die Menschen in unserem Land alle
die Möglichkeit haben einen Arbeitsplatz
zu haben mit dem sie ordentlich Geld
verdienen und dass sie auch alle die
Möglichkeit haben frei zu entscheiden
was für ein Auto Sie fahren das ist
unser Verständnis von Nachhaltigkeit und
davon habe ich hier heute nur von den
Redners unser Fraktion etwas gehört von
ihnen habe ich davon nichts gehört
und dann ist auch die Uhr von Dirk
Spaniel abgelaufen wenn auch mit
Verspätung gestartet jetzt kommen wir zu
Nils Gründer FDP-Fraktion erst seit
August im Parlament seinen Vorgänger
eben Parlament in der FDP-Fraktion war
Thomas Sattelberger der wegen
Krankheitsfällen in seinem näheren
persönlichen Umfeld sich zurückgezogen
hat aus dem Bundestag jetzt also Nils
Gründer einer recht neu dabei
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen liebe Kollegen die
Nachhaltigkeitsziele der Vereinten
Nationen sind wohl den meisten hier ein
Begriff sie sind Grundlage der deutschen
Nachhaltigkeitsstrategie mit ihren sechs
Prinzipien Kompass für ein nachhaltiges
Leben und die wohl größte
peacekeeping-mission des 21 jahrhunderts
wie spürbar die Konsequenzen von
globalen Konflikten in Deutschland sind
erleben die Bürgerinnen und Bürger jeden
Tag ob an der Kasse im Supermarkt oder
beim Tanken an der Zapfsäule
um diese Auswirkungen zu mindern spielt
Nachhaltigkeit eine entscheidende Rolle
nehmen wir unsere Verantwortung die wir
als viertgrößte Volkswirtschaft der Welt
haben war und lassen Nachhaltigkeit als
elementaren Bestandteil der globalen
Sicherheitsarchitektur mit in unser
Handeln einfließen
konkret denke ich dabei an folgende
Punkte
genau wie Freiheit Demokratie und
Menschenrechte ein unumstrittener Aspekt
der deutschen sicherheits- und
Verteidigungspolitik sind sollte
Nachhaltigkeit auch Teil dieses
Selbstverständnisses sein denn neben der
dringend notwendigen materiellen
Ausstattung trägt beispielsweise auch
die Prävention von Fluchtursachen wie
Dürren und Überflutungen zu
Konfliktvermeidung bei
der Stellenwert den Nachhaltigkeit in
der internationalen Gemeinschaft bereits
auf dem Papier genießt muss endlich auch
die den praktischen Umsetzungen gerecht
werden denn Nachhaltigkeit ist eine
Gemeinschaftsaufgabe die wir nur in
Kooperation mit allen Staaten umsetzen
können
und das ist keine Gedankensprünge
braucht um Nachhaltigkeit um
Sicherheitspolitik zusammenzudenken
zeigen vielerlei Beispiele sei es die
Auswirkungen von unter anderem
Ernteausfällen auf das politische Klima
in Syrien im Vorfeld des Bürgerkriegs
sei es Länder unabhängiger von endlichen
Ressourcen zu machen die die Gefahr von
Konflikten Bergen wie wir sie derzeit
unter anderem im Südsudan beobachten das
bundeswehrmandat für die UN-Mission im
Kooperation mit Schuba im Südsudan
Südsudan zeigt wie greifbar und
unmittelbar die Konsequenzen auch für
deutsche Staatsbürgerinnen und
Staatsbürger sind
wie meine Kolleginnen und Kollegen heute
bereits ausgeführt haben spielt die
Finanzierung der benannten Projekte
einen entscheidende Rolle ich möchte
eindringlich darauf hinweisen dass ein
Entwicklungshilfen für mehr
Nachhaltigkeit eben keine Spenden sind
sie sind Investitionen eine friedliche
Zukunft
außerdem sind sie Teil der Verantwortung
eines Landes das ein globalen
Führungsanspruch äußert
Entwicklungsgelder die in un
Nachhaltigkeitsziele fließend sind
Investitionen eine nachhaltige Zukunft
und in eine globale und stabile
Sicherheitsarchitektur vielen Dank
Nils Gründer für die FDP-Fraktion und
ihm wird jetzt folgen Dorothee Martin
aus der SPD-Fraktion sie ist
verkehrspolitische Sprecherin das Thema
Verkehr ist ja wiederholt schon
angesprochen worden im Zusammenhang mit
Nachhaltigkeit und das ist ja auch der
Sektor wo was ist die CO2 Reduzierung
angeht nach wie vor die größten Defizite
gibt
Gesetz zur Rede von der AFD sie hat
einfach noch mal dieses völlig düstere
und
menschenverachtende Bild gezeigt dass
ihre Politik prägt dass auch von einer
fachfremdheit nur so gekennzeichnet ist
nur ein Beispiel in der Lausitz es
stehen jetzt gerade noch mal tausend
neue Jobs durch neue Batteriezellen
Produktion das Verleugnen sie das
Missachten Sie dass es Ihre reine Angst
machen für die Menschen ihrem Land das
ist unseriös das ist verabreckend
wenn sie weiter pöbeln wollen gehen Sie
einfach raus hier ist kein Raum dafür
jetzt aber zu meiner Rede liebe
Kolleginnen Kollegen
Mobilität und Nachhaltigkeit das gehört
für uns Sozialdemokratien
Sozialdemokraten untrennbar zusammen und
unser Koalitionsvertrag ist da ganz klar
wir wollen die 2020er Jahre zu einem
Aufbruch in der mobilitätspolitik Nutzen
und eine nachhaltige eine effiziente
eine barrierefreie intelligente und
bezahlbare Mobilität für alle möglich
machen und dafür setzen wir auf Ausbau
von der Elektromobilität auf Stärkung
von Schiene von Wasserstraße Ausbau von
Radwegen vernetzte Angebote im ÖPNV und
vieles mehr um nur einige Beispiele zu
nennen und ein Prinzip in der
Nachhaltigkeitsstrategie das ist
nachhaltiges Bauen und Verkehrswende und
diese Verknüpfung finde ich gerade auch
bei Verkehrsprojekten unglaublich
wichtig denn auch da müssen wir bereits
in der Bau und Planungsphase
Nachhaltigkeit und Klimaschutz deutlich
priorisieren und dazu ein Beispiel aus
meiner Heimatstadt in Hamburg wird
derzeit eine neue U-Bahn quer durch die
ganze Stadt gebaut und die neue U5 wird
die klimaschonende U-Bahn in Deutschland
denn schon beim Bau sollen Emissionen so
weit wie möglich verringert werden nach
konventioneller Bauweise wurde errechnet
in stünde ein CO2-Ausstoß von fast drei
Millionen Tonnen aber dank einer unter
co2-aspekten eben völlig neuen
optimierten Planungen können diese
Emissionen im Bau schon um 70%
verringert werden und mit der neuen
U-Bahn werden dann nach Fertigstellung
täglich rund bislang 290.000 gefahrene
Kilometer PKW Kilometer eingespart
täglich eingespart das spart Emissionen
das entlastet unsere Straßen und das
reduziert auch lernen für die
Bürgerinnen und Bürger und dieses
Vorhaben das zeigt ganz beispielhaft mit
einem modernen mit einem nachhaltigen
ange schaffen wir den Umstieg vom Auto
auf den ÖPNV meine Damen und Herren
für uns als SPD ist wichtig nachhaltige
Mobilität bedeutet Teilhabe und ist
damit auch eine Frage der sozialen
Gerechtigkeit und damit diese Teilhabe
auf dem Land eben genauso möglich ist
wie in der Stadt brauchen wir allerorts
Ausbau von Bus und Bahnen und dabei
werden auch ganz neue Konzepte und
Innovationen und auch Reaktivierung von
stillgelegter Infrastruktur helfen um
ein Beispiel zu nennen ich habe mir im
Frühjahr mit unserem Kollegen Jürgen
berghan zusammen in ganz tolles Projekt
in Ostwestfalen angeguckt das monocap wo
Forscher einen autonomen fahrendes
Mobilitätsangebot entwickeln das eben
auch auf stillgelegten Bahnstrecken
eingesetzt werden kann und gerade solche
Innovationen müssen wir weiter
unterstützen und fördern
aber Nachhaltigkeit und Mobilität die
haben auch mit Stadtentwicklungen auch
mit Aufteilung des Straßenraums zu tun
und wenn man es mal die aktuellen
Regelungen in der Straßenverkehrsordnung
Straßenverkehrsgesetz angucken die sind
immer noch auf die autogerechte Stadt
ausgelegt das werden wir ändern indem
wir die Regelungen
die Regelungen mit den Zielen des
Klimaschutzes der Gesundheit und auch
der städtebaulichen Entwicklung
vereinbaren verankern dort deutlich mehr
Fokus draufsetzen dort den Kommunen auch
deutlich mehr Handlungsspielraum geben
und wir wissen alle die
Herausforderungen gerade zu erreichen
und kommt der Klimaziele im
Verkehrsbereich die sind riesig aber wir
können sie bewältigen gemeinsam anpacken
jetzt umsetzen mit voller Kraft voraus
vielen Dank
Dorothee Martin verkehrspolitische
Sprecherin der SPD-Fraktion und wir
beobachten ein klein wenig ob Yvonne mag
was die Bundestagsvizepräsidentin sich
vielleicht noch mal äußert zum
debattenverhalten zumindest auf einem
Teil hier im Plenum das doch auffällig
geworden ist in der letzten Zeit wir
schauen aber erst auf die nächsten
Redner erfolgreich ist aus der
Unionsfraktion und Mitglied im
parlamentarischen Beirat für nachhaltige
Entwicklung
zumindest die meisten von uns als
erfrischend wie wir uns heute in dieser
Debatte mit den verschiedensten
Ausprägungen und Spielarten dieses uns
alle betreffenden Themas
auseinandersetzen es wurde in diesem
Zusammenhang bereits mehrfach
angesprochen vielleicht wäre ein etwas
stärker ausgeprägter Rahmen für dieses
doch so zukunftsträchtige Thema auch ein
starkes Signal gewesen ein Signal auch
wie wichtig das Thema der Ampel
Bundesregierung ist früher gab es
nämlich mal wir haben das schon gehört
auch unter Beteiligung der Union
eingeführt mehrere
Nachhaltigkeitstage im Parlament
aber lassen Sie mich gerne auf einen
konkreten Bereich zu sprechen kommen der
im Bezug zur Nachhaltigkeit insbesondere
aus meiner Sicht als zuständiger
Berichterstatter eine ganz bedeutende
Rolle spielt nämlich der
Verbraucherschutz Nachhaltigkeit und
Verbraucherschutz gehen nämlich in der
Tat oftmals Hand in Hand beispielsweise
bei der Lebensdauer von Produkten ich
glaube wir haben das alles schon mal
erlebt dass bei technikgeräten wie im
Handys oder bei Laptops manchmal auf
gerade zu magische aber eben auch auf
frappierend auffällige Weise nach einem
bestimmten Zeit am besten ungefähr nach
Ablauf von Gewährleistung und Garantie
diese beginnen nicht mehr richtig zu
funktionieren
nachhaltig ist das nur für die Bilanz
der Produzenten der teure Reparaturen
oder in der Regel sogar ein Neukauf
anfallen
dazu passt natürlich auch besonders dass
auf vielen Ebenen geforderte und auch im
Koalitionsvertrag zu findende Recht auf
Reparatur dieses gerade auch mit Blick
auf die umfangreichen Herausforderungen
den wir uns aktuell gegenüberstehen ein
wichtiger Fingerzeig wir müssen weg von
der
Wegwerfmentalität denn in der Regel ist
Schrott eben nicht das was wir
umgangssprachlich damit bezeichnen
sondern Schrott insbesondere der
Elektroschrott ist ein richtig
wertvolles Gut oft voll mit Rohstoffen
die wiederverwertet gehören hier ergeben
sich riesige Chancen von der Schutz den
Erhalt und die Wiederverwendung von
Rohstoffen und Materialien das ist
Nachhaltigkeit in ihrer reinsten Form
aber bei allen ambitionierten Zielen die
wir uns in Deutschland setzen wir müssen
uns auch klar sein dass wir auf globaler
Ebene viel zu klein und zu unbedeutend
sind als das wir das Ruder alleine
herumreißen könnten
selbstverständlich kann und muss
Deutschland Vorreiter sein aber wenn die
USA China oder zwischen auch Indien
nicht mitziehen dann bewegt sich global
betrachtet eben fast nichts und wir
müssen leider feststellen dass die
weltweiten EU Nachhaltigkeitszielen noch
viel schwieriger und sehr zu erreichen
sind als das im eigenen Land schon der
Fall ist dabei gibt es eigentlich den
allergrößten Nachholbedarf
eingriffiges Beispiel wir verbieten bei
uns plastikstrohhalme während in anderen
Teilen der Welt mehr Plastiktüten als
Fische in den Flüssen schwimmen oder
nehmen wir den Abbau seltener Erden und
andere Rohstoffe unter Menschen
unwürdigen Verhältnissen in anderen
Teilen dieser Erde
Chemieanlagen die giftige Stoffe in
Gewässer einleiten oder die gewaltigen
Eingriffe in die Regenwälder unserer
Erde oftmals für Produkte die hier bei
uns auch aus Unwissenheit ganz
selbstverständlich und ohne mit der
Wimper zu zucken konsumiert werden
Nachhaltigkeit fängt eben auch schon
beim Verbraucherverhalten und damit auch
bei der Verbraucher Information an
auch deshalb dürfen wir unsere
Produktion Standort der weltweit die
höchsten Standards der drei Säulen der
Nachhaltigkeit aufweist ökonomisch
ökologisch und sozial nicht aus dem Land
treiben nicht nachhaltig ist es nämlich
die Produktion von Industriegütern in
einem Land mit hohen Standards und
moderner Technik in andere Teile der
Welt zu verlagern in denen oftmals keine
solchen Vorgaben eingehalten werden
müssen ist es denn nicht beispielsweise
absurd wenn bei der Produktion
beispielsweise in Südostasien das
vielfache an CO2 entsteht als wenn wir
das entsprechende Produkt selbst
herstellen würden vom ökologischen
Fußabdruck der Lieferwege einmal ganz
abgesehen wem ist dir geholfen dem
Weltklima mit Sicherheit nicht und auch
nicht den Menschen die oft unter
schlechtesten Arbeitsbedingungen und
miserabler Bezahlung die Luxusgüter des
Westens herstellen
mir persönlich sind die
nachhaltigkeitsdiskussionen auch hier im
Hause oftmals viel zu akademisch und zu
theoretisch ich würde mir mehr
politisches und gesellschaftliches
Handeln anhand der
nachhaltigkeitsgrundsätze wünschen so
wie wir das auch im parlamentarischen
Beirat für nachhaltig Entwicklung des
Deutschen Bundestages fördern mit Blick
auf die kommenden Generationen denen wir
verpflichtet sind wurde Nachhaltigkeit
bereits treffend mit nur einem Satz
beschrieben was immer du tust das tue
klug und bedenke das Ende vielen Dank
mehr handeln als Reben fordert nicht nur
dieses Mitglied des parlamentarischen
Beirats für nachhaltige Entwicklung das
war Volker Meierei sondern auch manche
andere die wir in dieser Debatte hier
schon gehört haben am Pult ist jetzt
Sandra detzer für die Fraktion Bündnis
90 die Grünen sie ist mitgegeben
Wirtschafts- und im Finanzausschuss
insgesamt vier nachhaltigkeitsjahre und
ich glaube das ist der Stern unter dem
wir unsere Arbeit steht
meine lieben Kolleginnen und Kollegen
die Frage der ob der Nachhaltigkeit ist
zum Glück längs geklärt es geht längst
um die Frage des wie und je schneller
wir konkret werden können desto besser
und als Abgeordnete wunderbaren
Wahlkreis Ludwigsburg in der schönen
Region Stuttgart sage ich aus voller
Überzeugung Geschwindigkeit erreichen
wir dann wenn wir Nachhaltigkeit noch
mehr zum Geschäftsmodell machen wenn wir
unternehmen und Beschäftigten die
Planungssicherheit geben und die
richtigen Rahmenbedingungen damit sie
ihre Innovationskraft für Nachhaltigkeit
einsetzen können dann werden eben jeden
Tag zig Millionen Einzelentscheidungen
in den Betrieben zugunsten der
Nachhaltigkeit getroffen und dann sind
wir auch so schnell wie wir sein müssen
um die Ökonomie und die Ökologie zu
versöhnen
und die gute Nachricht ist Unternehmen
und diese Beschäftigten haben sich eben
längst auf den Weg gemacht und
Mittelstand und Handwerk sehen
Nachhaltigkeit sehen regionale
Wirtschaftskreisläufe längst als Chance
in meiner Region beispielsweise gibt es
einen großen recycling-betonhersteller
die Firma fees der verdient jetzt schon
mehr Geld mit Recyclingbaustoffen als
mit primärer Rohstoffen und der schon
schon jetzt eben die natürlichen
Ressourcen damit und es gleichzeitig ein
wichtiger Akteur auf dem Markt und jetzt
sagt der er wird diese Sparte Abriss
auch weiter ausbauen weil natürlich in
dem Bereich unheimlich viel Musik drin
ist er hofft auf die Ampel erwartet auf
diese richtigen Rahmenbedingungen und
genau die wollen wir eben geben
wir werden wie geht es konkret das wurde
oft angesprochen und es ist ganz genau
richtig ich glaube wir müssen am
konkreten am wiederumsetzung jetzt
arbeiten wie wollen wir das machen wir
definieren Abfälle selbstverständlich
als Rohstoffe und werden so
Stoffkreisläufe schließen wir unter uns
schützen Unternehmen ihre Lieferketten
zu stabilisieren dann sehr wichtiges
Thema momentan
sekundärmaterialien mehr einzusetzen und
eben diese Kreisläufe gerade auch
regional zu schließen und wir machen
zirkuläres Wirtschaften attraktiver um
wegzukommen von der linearen
Wegwerfgesellschaft
Nachhaltigkeit ganz klar es ist oft
angesprochen worden schont unseren
Planeten und sichert die
Handlungsfreiheit auch künftiger
Generationen aber sie macht eben auch
unsere Wirtschaft wettbewerbsfähiger
unresellierenter und wir wollen globaler
Vorreiter sein auf dem Weg zu
nachhaltigem Wohlstand und wenn wir eben
weltweit viele Nachahmerinnen finden
wollen dann ist das der Schlüssel für
die Geschwindigkeit gerade in diesen
schwierigen Zeiten herzlichen Dank
und für die afd-fraktion hat das Wort
Martin Reichert
[Applaus]
sehr geehrter Herr Präsident sehr
geehrte Damen und Herren die
Nachhaltigkeitspolitik ist wie so vieles
was Bundesregierung fabrizierten links
totalitär die Grundlage aller
Nachhaltigkeit nämlich der Erhalt des
staatsvolks findet in ihr keinen Platz
in den letzten 50 Jahren starben in
Deutschland 6,1 Millionen Menschen mehr
als geboren wurden
230.000 allein 2021 über sechs Millionen
Menschen ohne Kriege nur durch
familienfeindliche Politik meine Damen
und Herren sechs Millionen Menschen die
heute als Fachkräfte zu Erhaltung
unseres rentengesundheits- und
Sozialsystems fehlen die sich in den
kommenden Jahrzehnten noch verstärkt und
sich in jährlichen sterbeüberschüssen
von 300.000 und mehr fortsetzt was zum
endgültigen Kollaps der Sozialsysteme
führt und in letz Konsequenz das
Aussterben des deutschen Volkes zur
Folge hat kein Wort zur Abwendung dieser
demografischen Katastrophe in den
nachhaltigkeitsprinzipien keine
Informationskampagnen zu den
verheerenden Folgen dieser Entwicklung
kein Konzept um diese Katastrophe
explizit abzuwenden nichts die Kosten
der Energiewende werden bis 2050
zwischen 1 und 3 Billionen Euro
geschätzt investieren Sie dieses Geld in
eine Geburten fördernde Politik die die
Lücke zwischen dem Kinderwunsch junger
Menschen und der tatsächlichen
Geburtenzahl schließt und dabei auch
noch die Kinder und familienarmut
tatsächlich bekämpft und dann eine
bevölkerungsbilanz ohne
sterbeüberschüsse ermöglicht
sie
lassen das deutsche Volk tatenlos
verändern sie reden von Nachhaltigkeit
und Artenschutz und lassen eines der
größten Kulturvölker der Weltgeschichte
nämlich das deutsche Volk untergehen das
ist ehrlos und verachtenswert
[Musik]
[Applaus]
und für die FDP-Fraktion hat das Wort
der Kollege Mohammad alhalak
[Applaus]
sehr geehrter Frau Präsidenten sehr
geehrte Kolleginnen und Kollegen wissen
Sie was mich beschäftigt Extremwetter
und wasserkreisläufer Nachhaltigkeit in
der Politik und der Geisteszustand der
Union und zwar in dieser Reihenfolge zu
dem ersten beiden Punkten möchte ich
folgendes sagen bei Fluten und
schutzreträgen wird Wasser zu tödlichen
Gefahr Herr Störer und der Regen bleibt
aus brechen existentinnen und
Kreisläufer zusammen
Starkregen und Dürre werden häufiger sie
zwingen uns unserem Umgang mit dem
Wasser anzupassen Überflutungen wie im
auertal grausame Bilder sie stehen bis
heute für die Notwendigkeit eines
Umdenkens und genau das tun wir
Sturzfluten sollen nicht nur kurzfristig
aufgefangen sondern langfristig
gespeichert werden auf der anderen Seite
haben wir ausgetrocknete Flüsse
sinkender Grundwasserpegel und
Ernteausfälle das heißt für uns wir
müssen Wasser nachhaltig entnehmen und
auch wiederverwenden
so führen wir dem Wasserkreislauf
insgesamt wieder mehr Wasser zu und
können obendrein Rohstoffe gewinnen wir
brauchen ein Frühwarnsystem ein Echtzeit
Datenmanagement so können wir auch
Probleme reagieren bevor sie zu Krisen
werden
aber um diese brillanten Ideen
umzusetzen
braucht es vor allem eines brillanter
Fachkräfte und dann schauen wir voller
Motivation auf dem Arbeitsmarkt und
sehen gehen in der Lehrer ein legefickte
fachkräftemarkt ein Ausbildungsmarkt der
mit unbesetzten Stellen gelernt
spätestens jetzt wird klar
nachhaltigkeit ist eine Grundhaltung der
Politik und zwar in allem bereichern in
der Ausbildung in der
Fachkräftegewinnung und in der
Einwanderung
wir brauchen die gut ausgebildeten
hochmotivierten ja auch die brillanten
Menschen die vor unser Haustier warten
und dann kommen wir zum und dann kommen
wir zum Geisteszustand der Union
da höre ich aus der Union von Herrn märz
das Gerede von sozialtourismus das ekelt
mich das widert mich an und das sage ich
Ihnen als abwassermeister ich kann mich
aus mit dem was Leute von sich lassen
meine Damen und Herren
meine Damen und Herren nachhaltigkeit
ist eine rationale Grundhaltung
vielleicht sollten wir das in der
Politik mal so verstehen
Panther Rey alles ist im Fluss und wenn
wir erst denken und dann reden wird der
Durchfluss minimiert vielen Dank
[Applaus]
und die Kollegin Leni preymaier der
SPD-Fraktion ist die nächste Rednerin
vielen Dank Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen liebe Frau
Ministerinnen was gibt Schöneres als in
seinem Geburtstag herzlichen Glückwunsch
in der Primetime des Deutschen
Bundestages über Nachhaltigkeit zu
sprechen und von den 17 Zielen der
Nachhaltigkeit habe ich mir die Nummer
fünf rausgesucht und die Nummer 5 ist
die Geschlechtergerechtigkeit und
ich glaube dass es auch wichtig ist dass
wir kapieren das Schlechte
Geschlechtergerechtigkeit die
Voraussetzung unter Motor für
nachhaltige Entwicklung und die
Zukunftsfähigkeit unsere Gesellschaft
ist dazu gehört die Beseitigung von
allen Formen der Diskriminierung und der
Gewalt gegen Frauen und Mädchen sowie
schädlicher Praktiken wie Kinderheirat
oder weiblicher Genitalverstümmelung
Ziele sind zudem die Anerkennung
unbezahlter sorgearbeit die volle und
wirksame Teilhabe von Frauen und ihre
Chancengleichheit bei der über Name von
Führungsrollen sowie der allgemeine
Zugang zu sexueller und reproduktiver
Gesundheit und reproduktiven Rechten
umsetzungsmittel sind Reformen für
gleiche Rechte in Bezug auf
wirtschaftliche Ressourcen Grundeigentum
und weitere vermögensformen die
verbesserte Nutzung der Informations-
und Kommunikationstechnologie und
durchsetzbare Rechtsvorschriften zur
Förderung des Selbstbestimmung aller
Frauen und Mädchen kurz wir müssen bei
allem was wir tun Fraueninteressen
berücksichtigen und das ist im Interesse
aller Menschen und im Interesse des
Planeten
Studienzeiten nur wenn Frauen und
Mädchen in all ihrer Verschiedenheit ein
Leben frei von geschlechtsspezifischer
Gewalt ermöglicht wird können Sie aktiv
am sozialen politischen und
wirtschaftlichen Leben teilnehmen das
weltweite Wirtschaftswachstum könnte um
20 Billionen US-Dollar zunehmen wenn
Frauen auf dem gleichen Niveau
ausgebildet werden und die gleiche
Anzahl von Arbeitsplätzen hätten wie
Männer hätten Frauen in der
Landwirtschaft weltweit den gleichen
Zugang zu Produktionsmitteln wie Männer
Läden die Erträge um 20 bis 30 Prozent
höher sind Frauen aktiv an
Friedensverhandlungen beteiligt steigen
die Chancen nachweislich um 20 Prozent
dass ein Friedensabkommen mindestens
zwei Jahre hält und eine Erhöhung des
Frauenanteils um zehn Prozent in den
nationalen Parlamenten für durch deren
häufig größeren auf Nachhaltigkeit und
Klimapolitik zu einem Rückgang von 0,24
Tonnen CO2 pro Kopf jedes Jahr eine
Erhöhung des Frauenanteils um zehn
Prozent in den Parlamenten darüber und
um noch mehr werden wir heute Abend bei
uns auch in der wahlrechtskommission
sprechen da diskutieren wir nämlich zum
dritten Mal das Thema Parität und ich
freue mich auf die Debatte und sie
blöden hier rum während ich rede während
safe seit Stunden bei Ihnen nicht eine
einzige Frau eine weibliche Abgeordnete
hier sitzt und gleichzeitig lassen Sie
ausschließlich Männer reden sechs Männer
sie haben bei dem Thema sie sind raus
sie haben nichts zu sagen und sie
blicken es auch überhaupt nicht
klar ist klar ist dass wir haben im New
York bei der UN frauenrechtskommission
im März diesen Jahres uns explizit mit
dem Thema Frauen und Klimawandel befasst
und klares wir müssen erstens die
Fraueninteressen berücksichtigen wir
müssen zweitens die Frauen beteiligen
und wir müssen drittens schauen dass die
Ressourcen so verteilt werden dass auf
Frauen genauso viel abfällt wie für die
Männer so und damit bin ich fertig
herzlichen Dank für die Aufmerksamkeit
Leni breimeier aus der
spd-fraktionsprecherin für Familie
Senioren Frauen und Jugend auch sie sie
muss sich von heftigen Zwischenrufen
angehört und geben lassen sie haben
vorhin das Präsidium und die Präsidentin
mit herr Präsident angesprochen in ihrer
Anrede ich gehe davon aus dass das ein
Versehen war wenn das das nächste Mal
passiert erteile ich ein Ordnungsruf und
der nächste
der nächste Redner in der Debatte ist
für die
cdu/csu-fraktion der Kollege Alexander
Engelhardt bis zumindest in diesem Punkt
mal eine Ermahnung in Richtung
afd-fraktion Alexander Engelhardt ist
jetzt am Pult und er spricht für die
cdu/csu-fraktion
tin sehr geehrte Damen und Herren liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen
gegen Ende unserer Debatte können wir
feststellen wie vielschichtig und breit
man Nachhaltigkeit diskutieren kann im
Kern ist entscheidend dass nachhaltiges
Handeln auf drei gleichberechtigten
Säulen ruht Ökonomie Ökologie und
Soziales
gerade in herausfordernden Zeiten wie
diesen ist es wichtig mit einer
nachhaltigen Politik alle drei
Dimensionen zusammenzuführen
diese große Aufgabe erfüllt die
Bundesregierung aktuell nicht in den
letzten Wochen und Monaten spüren wir
die Konsequenzen wenn dieser Dreiklang
aus dem Gleichgewicht gerät wir können
es in den verschiedenen
transformationsbereichen sehen wie
zutreffend in der deutschen
Nachhaltigkeitsstrategie umrissen werden
wie ein zu eindimensionales Handeln eine
nachhaltige Entwicklung behindert
zum Beispiel beim nachhaltigen agrar-
und Ernährungssystem es soll uns mit
einer Vielfalt an der schwinglichen
Lebensmittel versorgen und gleichzeitig
den Schutz der Umwelt gewährleisten in
Deutschland können wir dank unserer
Landwirte sagen dass sie einen hohen
Grad an Selbstversorgung beispielsweise
mit Getreide haben
wenn wir uns die aktuellen Konsequenzen
unserer strategischen Abhängigkeiten in
anderen Bereichen anschauen dann muss
das auch so bleiben
die EU-Kommission plant im Rahmen des
green Deals Maßnahmen die zur
tragseeinbußen und zusätzlich zu einer
Entnahme von Flächen für die
landwirtschaftliche Produktion führen
werden
laut einer Berechnung des Deutschen
Bauernverbandes könnte das EU
naturschutzpaket zu einer deutlichen
oder vollständigen Nutzungsbeschränkung
von 5 Millionen Hektar
landwirtschaftlicher Fläche führen dies
entspricht ein Drittel der aktuell
genutzten Fläche das wird erhebliche
Konsequenzen auf die Lebensmittelpreise
und die Ernährungssicherung haben die
sozial gerechte Dimension ist hier das
Lebensmittel erschwinglich bleiben da
hat Deutschland auch eine globale
Verantwortung nur durch wochenlangen
Druck der Union haben wir in der
Diskussion um die Stilllegung von
Flächen erreicht das wertvolle
Ackerflächen am gunststandort
Deutschland nicht aus der
Nahrungsmittelproduktion genommen werden
[Applaus]
ernsthafte Sorgen mache ich mir um
kleine regionale Strukturen die nicht
zuletzt für die Vielfalt unsere
Lebensmittel stehen so sind
beispielsweise
3200 eingetragene Brotsorten der
innungsbäcker in Deutschland
immaterielles Kulturerbe der UNESCO
[Applaus]
gerade bei den Grünen ist das
romantische Bild von Landwirtschaft mit
Kühen auf der grünen Wiese und der
dinkelbackstube um die Ecke hoch im Kurs
doch insbesondere sie beschleunigen
durch unzureichendes Krisenmanagement im
Hinblick auf niedrigere Energiekosten
den Strukturwandel hin zu großen
Betriebsstrukturen die vorhandenen
Möglichkeiten um die Strom die
Strommenge zu steigern lagen lange genug
auf den Tisch
im ländlichen Raum sind viele kleine
Betriebe wie Bäckereien und Metzgereien
tragischerweise schon dabei zu schließen
dabei werden Sie nicht nur als
vielfältige lebensmittelversorger und
Arbeitgeber dringend gebraucht sondern
auch als lebendiger Treffpunkt in
unseren Dörfern und Gemeinden
das ist ein wichtiger Faktor für
Lebensqualität den wir gerade verlieren
aufgrund der hohen Inflation können sich
die Menschen hochwertige ökologisch und
regional produzierte Lebensmittel immer
weniger leisten wir sehen es aktuell am
Beispiel daran dass Bio-Produkte
zunehmend in großen discounterketten
gekauft werden während kleine regionale
Bioläden zweistellige Umsatzeinbrüche
hinnehmen müssen auch das befeuert den
Strukturwandel
als weiteren transformationsbereich gibt
die Nachhaltigkeitsstrategie das Ziel
einer schadstofffreien Umwelt aus das
soll im Zusammenspiel von
chemikalienrechtlichen Anforderungen
Wasser und Emissionsschutz erreicht
werden in Deutschland und Europas sind
sie allerdings gerade im Begriff für
dieses Ziel unsere Industrie zu opfern
und die ökonomische sowie die soziale
Säule wegzureißen
die wachsenden bürokratischen
Anforderungen in diesem Bereich
erdrückend unsere Betriebe
so Bergen die Vorschläge für neue
Regelungen der
industrie-emissionsrichtlinie die Gefahr
dass sich Genehmigungsverfahren für
Industrieanlagen weiterverkomplizieren
im Chemikalienrecht sehen wir mit einer
Verschärfung der reach und clp-
auch wenn manche Ziele aus Brüssel gut
gemeint sind befürchte ich massive
Verlagerungseffekte aus Europa weg
das wäre nicht nur ökonomisch und
soziale ne Katastrophe sondern macht
unsere umweltschutzbemühungen zur Faust
sowie die Bundesregierung permanent
betont man dürfte Krisen nicht
gegeneinander ausspielen möchte ich
betonen dass alle drei Säulen der
Nachhaltigkeit das Grundgerüst unserer
sozialen Marktwirtschaft sein müssen
ich sehe im eigenen Betrieb was die
mangelnde Krisenbewältigung der Ampel
gerade für kleine regionale
Handwerksbetriebe bedeutet die Umsätze
brechen ein die Kosten steigen gestern
noch zukunftsfähige Betriebe sind heute
in Gefahr
daher mein Appell an die Bundesregierung
bringen sie Ökologie Ökonomie und
Soziales ins Gleichgewicht
[Applaus]
und für die SPD-Fraktion hat die
Kollegin Franziska Maschek das Wort
Franziska ist im Ausschuss für Wohnen
statt Entwicklung Bauwesen und Kommunen
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrte Kolleginnen und Kollegen sehr
geehrte Damen und Herren wir wollten
unsere Erde massiv aus wenn wir alle so
leben würden die wir hier in Deutschland
bräuchten wir drei Erden als Mitglied
des Bauausschusses muss ich feststellen
der Bausektor trägt einen großen Anteil
dazu bei bei einem Anteil von 5,5% an
der deutschen Bruttowertschöpfung
verursacht nur der Bausektor alleine 25%
des CO2-Ausstoßes und verbraucht 40
Prozent der erzeugten Energien
Nachhaltigkeit meine Damen und Herren
geht anders
man sollte meinen diese Zahlen hätte in
der Vergangenheit dazu geführt mit
innovativen Ideen oder Forschungsbudgets
etwas zu bewegen denn Bildung
Wissenschaft und Forschung sind immerhin
Teil der deutschen
nachhaltigkeitsprinzipien seit 2016 doch
die Bauforschung ist seit jeher deutlich
unterfinanziert meine Damen und Herren
hier besteht akuter Handlungsbedarf
wir brauchen immer mehr Wohnraum für
eine wachsende Weltbevölkerung aber mehr
bauen und gleichzeitig Ressort den
Ressourcenverbrauch zu minimieren ja wie
soll das gehen darauf gibt es nur wenige
Antworten aktuell hier können wir mal
ganz kurz in die Praxis gucken in
Dresden gibt es ein schönes
Forschungsprojekt an der TU dort gibt es
den forschungsverband C3 der hat sich
einen grundlegenden Paradigmenwechsel
zum Ziel gesetzt
wir waren mit der Fraktion in Dresden
und haben uns das carbonhaus ein Carbon
Cube angeschaut gestern war die
offizielle Eröffnung sie kennen alle
Stahlbeton die sind dicken Trägerplatten
man kann einfach den Stahl durch Carbon
ersetzen viel leichter viel tragfähiger
was wir damit schaffen können es 50%
Materialdicke sparen bis zu 30 Prozent
CO2-Emissionen einsparen und das ganze
Bauwerk kann Bauwerk kann bis zu 50%
leichter werden ringsrum gibt es weitere
Forschungszweige die sich mit
carbongewinnung zum Beispiel aus Algen
beschäftigen und diese wiederum
speichern CO2 das sind doch großartige
Ansätze das ist die Praxis dort gibt es
die Forschung oder es gibt zum Beispiel
auch die Forschung an grünem Zement wir
haben die Beispiele in der Praxis da
was wir bei all den Diskussionen um
Nachhaltigkeit aber nicht vergessen
dürfen ist die Akzeptanz bei den
Menschen vor Ort und hier sind wir
wieder bei meinem Lieblingsthema der
Stärkung der Kommunen denn sie gestalten
gemeinsam mit die Menschen ein
wesentlichen Teil des Alltags und des
Gemeinwesens daher müssen sie
konzeptionell und finanziell in die Lage
versetzt werden gemeinsam mit
Zivilgesellschaft aber auch Wirtschaft
Lösungen zu arbeiten und sie vor allem
vor Ort umzusetzen ich bin
Sozialarbeiterin wir besprechen dann wir
sprechen dann von beteiligungsprojekten
Selbstwirksamkeit und Erfahrungswissen
die Menschen möchten nicht belehrt
werden sie möchten sich selbst an der
Problemlösung beteiligen nehmen wir die
Menschen ernst nehmen wir Sie in der
Transformation mit es fehlt nicht an
theoretischem Wissen es fehlt an
Bewusstsein und eine praktischen
Umsetzung im Alltag oder wie es eins
meine Professorin für Modern Tanz an der
pauluca-schule in Dresden sagte gewusst
wie spart Energie herzlichen Dank
Franziska Maschek aus der SPD-Fraktion
und wir nähern uns so langsam dem Ende
dieser Debatte aber zunächst kommt noch
Robert farle der bis vor kurzem noch
Mitglied der afd-fraktion gewesen ist
jetzt aus der Fraktion ausgetreten ist
weil eben die Haltung der AFD gegenüber
Russland zu kritisch war
Robert farle
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrte Damen und Herren
angesichts explodierender Energiepreise
ausfahrender Stromnetze kaputter Währung
mit galoppierender Inflation
Massenzuwanderung die Industrialisierung
eingeschränkter Meinungsfreiheit
drohender Massenarbeitslosigkeit
Zerstörung des Mittelstandes mit
wachsender Armut fragen sich jeden Tag
immer mehr Menschen was steckt hinter
all diesen Entwicklungen meine Antwort
die globale Agenda hierfür wurde 1992
auf der Konferenz für nachhaltige
Entwicklung in Rio de Janeiro
aufgestellt Stichwort klappt of Rome
unter dem Deckmantel des Klimaschutzes
und wohlklingender Phrasen von
Nachhaltigkeit
Gleichheit und Gerechtigkeit
verbirgt sich
ein totalitärer Staatsdirigismus
Mangelwirtschaft und die Kontrolle über
alle Lebensbereiche der Menschen
kurz die ganze links grüne Agenda von
Habeck und Co
dahinter steht eine Kumpanei von Politik
und Großkonzernen gesteuert aus den USA
die das gesamte staatliche Handeln in
immer mehr Ländern in der Welt bestimmt
das haben wir in der corona-krise sehr
gut feststellen können welchen Einfluss
zum Beispiel Bill Gates auf die WHO
genommen hat hinter dem Prinzip der
Übernahme von globaler Verantwortung
verbirgt sich der wohlstands-transfer
ins Ausland zum Beispiel die 10
Milliarden Euro an Indien für
angeblichen Klimaschutz die Erhaltung
von natürlichen Lebensgrundlagen mein
Smart Cities und die Vernachlässigung
des länd einen Raums bis hin zu solchen
Sachen wie krankenhausschließungen und
so weiter und so fort nachhaltiges
Wirtschaften bedeutet Planwirtschaft
statt Marktwirtschaft staatliche
Kontrolle über die Produktionsmittel
Absenkung des privaten Konsums auf allen
Ebenen
Insekten statt Fleisch Fahrräder statt
Autos Waschlappen statt Dusche da weiß
doch jeder Deutsche was Sie wirklich
wollen
Verbote statt Freiheit
ganz nach dem Motto von Klaus Schwab du
wirst nichts besitzen aber du wirst
glücklich sein
das wollen wir nicht und das will auch
ich persönlich nicht und wenn ich nach
Nachhaltigkeit gefragt werde dann sage
ich Ihnen was die wichtigste Frage der
Nachhaltigkeit ist wir müssen alles tun
um eine Eskalation des ukraine-konflikts
zu verhindern und Frieden mit Russland
zu schließen und einer europäische
Sicherheitsarchitektur in Gang bringen
und das setzt voraus dass man auch die
Berechtigten Sicherheitsinteressen eines
Gegners anerkennt und das tun sie bis
heute nicht anstatt einer solchen
Offensive vielen Dank frau Präsidentin
ich habe mich diesmal wirklich bemüht in
drei Minuten einzuhalten vielen Dank
Robert Vahle ehemals afd-fraktion und da
sage noch jemand dass man nicht alles
sagen dürfe hierzu Lande vorletzte
Rednerin in dieser Debatte ist raschand
Nassa aus der SPD-Fraktion sie ist
Mitglied im Ausschuss für Arbeit und
Soziales
was übrigens auch von der
Meinungsfreiheit gedeckt ist uns hat ein
bisschen wehgetan jetzt aber hören wir
auf so ein Blödsinn zu erzählen sehr
geehrte Frau Präsidentin meine sehr
verehrten Damen und Herren werte
Kolleginnen und Kollegen ich bin dankbar
dass wir diese Debatte heute führen und
möchte als stellvertretende Sprecherin
für Arbeit und Soziales der
SPD-Bundestagsfraktion den Fokus genau
auf diesen Bereich legen eine
nachhaltige arbeitsmarkt- und
Sozialpolitik ist essentiell denn wir
können uns den Luxus nicht mehr leisten
in und ausländische Potenziale einfach
liegen zu lassen wir müssen da einfach
viel besser werden und deshalb bin ich
bundesinnenministerin Nancy fazer
dankbar das hier ist vor kurzem mit
meinem Interview mit der FAZ ganz klar
und deutlich gesagt hat dass wir
Bürokratie abbauen ausländische
Abschlüsse schneller anerkennen und vor
allem dafür sorgen dass die Hürden auf
den deutschen Arbeitsmarkt zu kommen aus
dem Weg geräumt werden sollen denn
unsere Gesellschaft wird immer älter und
wir müssen den Arbeitsmarkt nachhaltig
stabilisieren dafür brauchen wir unter
anderem
400.000 Menschen im Jahr die aus dem
Ausland in den deutschen Arbeitsmarkt
einsteigen und dafür stellen wir in
diesem Herbst die Weichen mit einem
neuen fachkräfteeinwanderungsgesetz das
einen Namen auch wirklich verdient hat
zu einer nachhaltigen
Arbeitsmarktpolitik gehört aber eben
auch das riesige inländische Potenzial
zu heben wir leben in einer Zeit in der
sich der Arbeitsmarkt rasant und radikal
verändert auf einmal gibt es neue Jobs
ganze Branchen stellen sich um bestimmte
Jobs gibt es schon nicht mehr oder
werden zukünftig nicht mehr existieren
die Transformation der Arbeit macht den
Menschen Angst und deshalb ist es unsere
aufgabewerte Kolleginnen und Kollegen
die Menschen auf diesem Weg mitzunehmen
unser Ziel muss Vollbeschäftigung sein
gute Arbeitsplätze gute Löhne das klingt
ambitioniert und das ist es auch aber je
mehr Menschen in
sozialversicherungspflichtiger Arbeit
sind desto besser können unsere sozialen
Sicherungssysteme nachhaltig
stabilisiert werden denn wenn Menschen
Hilfe vom Sozialstaat brauchen dann
sollen sie die auch bekommen deshalb bin
ich Bundesarbeitsminister Hubertus hält
dankbar dass er gemeinsam mit uns nicht
nur den Mindestlohn zum 1 Oktober auf 12
Euro anhebt sondern auch mit dem
Bürgergeld eine der größten
sozialpolitischen Reformen der letzten
20 Jahre in die geleitet
wir schaffen mehr Sicherheit Vertrauen
und Respekt im Umgang mit Menschen im
SGB II unter anderem mit der
vertrauenszeit dem weiterbildungsbonus
und individuellen Coaching werden wir
dafür sorgen dass Menschen endlich nicht
mehr sinnlos in irgendwelche Jobs
vermittelt werden und dann nur um wenige
Monate später wieder beim Jobcenter
sitzen das hat nämlich mit nachhaltiger
Sozialpolitik so rein gar nichts zu tun
das neue Bürgergeld kommt zum ersten
Januar 23 und ich freue mich sehr dass
wir die alte Praxis endlich hinter uns
lassen und ansonsten wünsche ich uns
noch viel Erfolg bei der Umsetzung der
Nachhaltigkeitsziele sie sind
ambitioniert aber sie weisen uns den
richtigen Weg vielen Dank
und die letzte Rednerin in der Debatte
ist die Kollegin Tina Rudolph für die
SPD
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen der
demokratischen Parteien Liebe
Zuschauerinnen und Zuschauer in vielen
Reden ist bereits darauf eingegangen
worden welche Auswirkungen global aber
auch hier in Deutschland für die
Menschen spürbar geworden sind weil wir
nicht nachhaltig genug gelebt haben die
schockierenden Bilder des
ahrtalhochwassers Hochwasser an vielen
anderen Orten in meinem Wahlkreis zum
Beispiel in Mosbach jährliche Waldbrände
Wasser das in vielen Gegenden knapp wird
ausfallende ernten längst leiden nicht
mehr nur für eine rabelgruppen sondern
große Teile der Bevölkerung im Sommer
unter der enormen Hitze für die der
menschliche Körper nicht gemacht ist die
das Herz-Kreislauf-System belastet und
zum Beispiel das Risiko für Frühgeburten
erhöht
die globale Verringerung von
Biodiversität und die Verschiebung
klimatischer Grenzen führen zu Pandemien
und bringen Krankheiten an neue Orte so
breitet sich zum Beispiel die Asiatische
Tigermücke inzwischen auch in
Deutschland aus die Gelbfieber das
Denken und das siegervirus überträgt
auch dieses Beispiel zeigt Klimawandel
ist nichts dass sich nur weit entfernt
abspielt in der anderen Ländern sondern
was auch hier mit voller Wucht spürbar
ist um reagieren zu können müssen wir
noch viel stärker in sozial gerechte und
ökologisch nachhaltige Gesellschaften
investieren wir müssen in allen
Bereichen neu und mutig denken und zum
Beispiel nach dem Ansatz der help in all
policies genau prüfen die jegliches
Handeln und politische Entscheidungen
auf das Klima und die Gesundheit wirken
wir müssen viel stärker und
interdisziplinärer nach dem Konzept von
One health schauen wie sich die
Wechselwirkungen zwischen Umwelt und
Klima zwischen Tiergesundheit und
menschlicher Gesundheit gestalten und
diese Bereiche zusammendenken auch hier
nochmal ein kurzer Werbeblock für den
parlamentskreis von Herrn erst jüngst
haben die G7 unter deutscher
Präsidentschaft die Verpflichtung
ausgerufen in den nächsten 20 Jahren zu
einem nachhaltigen Gesundheitssystem zu
kommen das ist von großer Bedeutung denn
gerade dieser Bereich der für den Schutz
menschlicher Gesundheit zuständig ist
ist durch einen hohen
Ressourcenverbrauch und hohe Emissionen
gekennzeichnet und damit gleichzeitig
paradoxerweise Gefährder unserer aller
Gesundheit es gibt also dringenden
Reformbedarf in Richtung Nachhaltigkeit
bei der Produktion beim Transport und
der Entsorgung beim Essen in den
krankenhauskantinen beim
Energieverbrauch und bei der
Gebäudesubstanz des Gesundheitssektors
und es ist frustrierend für die
Beschäftigten im Gesundheitswesen wenn
sie aus ökonomischen Gründen keine
mehrwegprodukte verwenden können oder
Medikamente die weniger CO2 verursachen
weil die Folgekosten in Richtung
Nachhaltigkeit nicht berücksichtigt
worden und die Akteure im
Gesundheitssystem wollen hier handeln
dass der deutsche Ärztetag 2020 den
Klimawandel zur zentralen Frage des 21
jahrhunderts erklärt hat ist nur ein
Beispiel hierfür und wir müssen also
prüfen und das BMG ist die
dankesweiterweise auch tätig geworden
bereits wie das Gesundheitssystem
effizienter gestaltet werden kann aber
auch ob die Menschen im
Gesundheitssystem ausreichend in der
Lage sind Mittel im Sinne der
Nachhaltigkeit einzusetzen ich bin
deswegen überzeugt dass wir auch darüber
diskutieren sollten ob es sinnvoll sein
kann das Wirtschaftlichkeitsgebot im
Paragraphen 12 des SGB 5 und mal
nachhaltigkeitsgebot zu erweitern jetzt
habe ich noch 10 Sekunden für die
globale Perspektive über die ich
eigentlich viel länger reden müsste weil
wir uns auch international natürlich
viel stärker engagieren müssen damit das
erste D3 das zentrale gesundheitsziel
erreicht wird wir sehen in vielen
Ländern des globalen Südens einen
backlash Richtung Prävention Richtung
der Bekämpfung von Krankheiten Frauen
und Mädchen leiden hier besonders und
wie in Deutschland ebenfalls bitte zum
Schluss adressiert hat müssen wir
Gesundheitssysteme im globalen Süden
Stärken bitte gestatten sie zum Schluss
noch die rhetorische Frage wird das
alles Geld kosten ja wenn wir nicht
investieren würden
deswegen lassen sie uns Handeln danke
schön
ja Tina Rudolph von der SPD Fraktion
hier als letzte Rednerin zu dieser
vereinbarten Debatte zur deutschen
Nachhaltigkeitsstrategie dreieinhalb
Stunden hat der Deutsche Bundestag sich
heute für diese Debatte Zeit genommen es
gab keine Gesetzentwürfe oder keine
Anträge die jetzt abgestimmt werden das
ist ja sozusagen
für eine vereinbarte Debatte üblich